Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
No bathroom breaks now.
Real deceptive.
Today, we're going to be finishing Mouse PI for our hire.
Oh, yeah, before I do, I don't know how long this game is
going to take me.
So let me order dinner first, just in case.
Just in case that it's another Poe situation.
So give me a sec.
Also, my voice is sort of dying right now.
So, I might have to take two to three days off.
Maybe three days off because I need to rest.
I did a lot of long streams this week.
So, I might have to rest my voice because you can tell.
Not sounding too great.
But, we'll do another long stream today.
Just because I do want to finish MousePI for our hire.
So, we can start a new game series for next week.
That the member goons have selected for us.
But let me order my...
food real quick.
All right.
Let me order my food.
Let me order from the place I wanted to order yesterday, but
couldn't because I got bucked over by Poe.
Poe's got me.
I get a...
Let's see.
I'm gonna get...
Ooh, I want a tiramisu.
Yes, sir.
I'll get myself a tiramisu.
misu and then also a you know what i will get a takoyaki
yeah i will treat myself to some takoyakis too yeah i
deserve it i deserve a good takoyaki well welcome to tomato
fire welcome welcome gonna treat myself to something nice
all right so we might have a little food break in between
all right i'm gonna put alarm on just in case, because I
don't trust myself.
Yes, welcome back to Mouse P.I.
for hire.
Everything's coming together now, guys.
It's all coming together.
Did I have screen shake on?
I don't remember.
Because everything reset itself, right?
Was screen shake on, guys?
Because I legitimately don't remember what I had.
Today's my birthday at my time zone.
May 10th, by the way, it means to stay in last year, so can
I celebrate it twice as much?
Of course, Morph- English is hard today.
Of course, Morph-Laws.
Of course, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Morph-Laws.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
All right, I hope you have a great birthday.
birthday more funds and watch me complete this game that's
my birthday present to you i will finish this game what a
great birthday present oh i don't work i turned off dv
already um you'll have to refresh it uh or unless you want
to lose your power and then just don't refresh uh all right
yeah it says it's you have to refresh it and then your power
will be gone um but yes was my uh was my
DVR was off Oh yeah, yeah, DVR is off Yeah, DVR is off
Unlimited power What will I do?
It was off Alright, screen shake off Yeah, I think
everything got reset For sure I don't know if I'm gonna be
lagging or anything So we're gonna find out live We're gonna
find out if I'm lagging or not Right here, right now
Cause I don't remember We adjusted anything else than that.
Oh, I did?
Adjusted my... No.
Everything else should be good.
Yeah, alright.
Continue.
Fuck, we do a lot!
Does it reset my sense?
It doesn't, right?
So I don't know.
Let me double check everything.
I know there's no motion blurring because this is a good
game.
Hey, Dougie.
I had a crazy dream where you played in your game.
convene but instead of playing on committee you play vampire
crawlers i don't know what dream you're talking about uh i
mean i don't remember that actually ever happening in real
life but that seems like a good dream uh but we definitely
played that did not happen yes that did not happen last
stream though clothing in the super chat thank you thank you
all right let's see i think everything else is good what a
strange dream oh i'm like dashing in Oh, I know.
There's no dash, right?
There's no dash in this game, right?
I don't remember.
I know I just played this two days ago.
Alright, I think that's good.
I don't think there was a dash.
I think it was just...
We... Fuck it, we go in.
All I did was go on a bathroom break.
Is that really a crime?
I'm paid by the hourly, not by how much I do.
There is a dash?
Oh, there is like...
I know there's like...
Okay, there was the kick.
Which is my kick?
Hello?
Which one was my kick button?
F?
Okay, F.
Okay.
Alright, F is my kick button.
Sorry, I gotta remember all my controls.
I've been playing a bit, maybe a little too much vampire
crawlers.
Just a little bit, you know?
Just a little bit too much.
All right.
Oh, there is a dash.
Okay, there it is.
I forgot.
Oh, I forgot, like, the dash is just, like, not as fun to
use because you can't use it when you're jumping.
All right, we're ready.
This game would be a little better if it had more bones.
You're right.
All right, let's go to the psyche ward.
The insane asylum.
I think it was, like, right here.
Don't worry, we will solve this mystery soon.
I can't wait to be paid a whole $1 afterwards, too.
After all my hard work, that whole $1.
Here we go.
The creepy mile.
Oh.
That's what.
Thank God for the 1930s when I can shoot and ask questions
later.
proven innocent.
The good old days.
Holy shit, what the fuck?
Yeah, it's so tanky now.
They're so tiny, but yeah, it's so tanky.
Alright, that should be good.
That should be all of them.
Unless...
What?
Who still exploded?
Okay.
Alright, nice.
At least they exploded each other.
Wait, where am I supposed to actually go?
This way.
Okay.
That means I can go this way.
Oh.
Whoa.
Wait, where did he go?
It was right there.
Oh?
This is the- Oh!
This is whoo!
Whoo!
Oh my god, jump scare.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, there's a number.
Uh, the future is bright.
Yeah, sure, according to the detonation test.
Wait, there's a number for this.
What number could it be?
Oh, that...
Wait, is that what happened to that guy?
What is the number?
It can't be boobs this time.
It's three digits long.
I don't see any signs.
There's no signs anywhere.
It's Bob.
Yeah, dude, because this time it's just Bob.
I
don't know what number this could be.
One, two, three.
All right, we'll come back to it.
Maybe we'll figure it out later.
I knew there was a mouse in there.
It's always a mouse in there.
Breeze?
Goodbye.
Oh, that means we can't come back to it.
We can't come back, then that means we have...
What the fuck?
Where are the clues for this area?
How can we be a detective that there's nothing to detect?
Okay, that says... Okay, there should be a number somewhere.
A number should be hiding somewhere, right?
unless there's a shortcut to come back here all right
whatever whatever I don't even care that much anyway is it
the clock oh my god it could be the clock you're so right
what time does it say it says 1 30 35 40 45 50 150
oh my god dokey you're so smart I can't I knew you would
figure this out dokey
150.
10, 7, 8, 9, 10.
What?
Is that not 150?
Oh my gosh.
No, wait.
That doesn't make sense.
It'd be 1250.
But then like, there's not enough numbers.
For 1250.
Yeah, but there's only three digits.
Oh, maybe it's one two zero five?
Maybe.
One two five.
What?
Maybe you should check the back of your debit card.
What's the three digits of your debit card?
That could be the password.
Or 050?
Oh, 050.
Wait, you're right.
Wait, I'm right.
Oh, Doki, you're so smart.
Oh.
50.
What?
What could it be?
Whatever, it's just one armor.
It's not that important.
I don't need it.
I'm not even thinking about it right now.
I didn't care that much anyway.
Not thinking about it at all.
It's not living run free in my head.
I couldn't figure it out.
That we couldn't figure it out.
Guys, just remember.
You also didn't figure it out.
Just remember that we didn't figure it out.
Oh my god, it locked the door the moment I got in here.
I got in the first try.
What's the answer then, huh?
What's the answer?
We got in the first try.
Likely story.
Should be it.
Oh, there's more.
Wait, where are they?
Oh!
Okay, the smaller mice are tankier now for some reason.
Usually it would be like one headshot and that's it.
I need this health potion real quick.
And I know that there's a mouse in there.
There's always a mouse in there.
What's this guy doing so far away?
Uh...
Kacks.
Hey, yo.
I'm a professional.
Thank God I'm a good guy.
I'm on your team.
Alright, where am I supposed to go?
Okay, we're supposed to go up.
Which means there might be some loot here.
Where are you?
Dude, that's on the other side.
That's on the other side.
Look, it's just...
How do I even get on this side?
Oh, wait, that's where I came from.
Whoops.
There you go.
Kill them just for the fun of it.
Yeah.
Might be...
Wait, where'd I go?
Oh, Dash.
Warad.
That's where I go.
So he mixes some ink and discovers the perfect ratio for the
unknown purpose.
Big wolf.
I hear Bano's name one more time.
And I'll go pew bang.
And somebody found me some speakers.
Did this guy have a heart attack?
How?
Why is he writing in an accent?
For fondue's sake.
Me, thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you.
It's like, did he have a concussion?
And then he just started speaking French?
I was hearing about that.
There's like people who would like get like a concussion or
something.
Or like brain trauma.
And then suddenly it starts speaking in a different accent.
Yeah, but he's writing in a German accent.
A German...
No, he's just European.
I remember reading about something how, like, a woman got,
like, a heart attack or a stroke.
And then suddenly she woke up speaking in a Chinese accent.
And she was, like, white or something.
And people were like, how does that happen?
like and you just like never been to Asia
there's one word like there was a case where like um someone
woke up and just started speaking in French the racism got
out the top shell care tractor now just a washed up bluehead
extramarital affairs can be learned on for leverage thing
every so often a church shows up by his pillow must be a
work of some crappy little ghost or something where are all
the patients oh oh it would be a oh it's just a it's
decontamination that's all right decontamination show smells
you're just decontaminating me right surely there's not some
bad gas what how did millie here get here this gas is in
some trippy gas right oh no it's back man it's back man
arkham asylum we're back you had too much time way off
cheese and bunny pills i what the how the hell did she get
there follow milly it's arkham asylum time we're back it's
like We never left.
I got scarecrowed, yeah.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I didn't know if I could...
If the...
If the double jump resets.
Okay, double jump does not reset.
That's good to know.
Alright, there's many.
Can't get up there yet.
though um i'll make sure
nice another one did someone lose their child
fuck okay that's fine that's fine wait my i wanted to i
wanted to drop down anyway because there's a secret tunnel
that's right I knew there was a secret.
All alone.
Is he still shooting me?
The fucking bugs outside?
All planned.
We meant to do that.
That's right.
I was like, oh, it must be a secret down here.
Oh, I thought it'd be like...
I mean, this is...
Why would it give me TNT?
Unless...
No.
Why did it give me TNT, though?
Is there a wall?
That's not a wall?
A totally normal wall?
No.
It's not.
What the fuck?
Get out of here.
All right, let's go back up.
Let's try this again.
Oh my god forgot how I have glide I forgot okay that makes
more sense now that actually makes more sense all right
never mind that did not make sense at all never mind give me
let me try this again
okay now I got my double jump back and then save
Oh Holy shit.
It's an ambush
Oh, where did they even come from?
Where could they even spawn in?
The bad guy jumpscare.
What the fuck?
That's right Think about diving bombing me again next time.
Alright, this way.
I think this is a shortcut, right?
Yeah, this is a decontamination area.
Oh, sorry, Mindy.
Oh, never mind.
She wasn't real.
Wait, where did my poison go?
Does it not work because they're already dead?
Oh, there they are.
Oh, okay, there's the crazy people.
The crazies, shrews.
the old-timey teleportation oh yeah like how how the
government had iphones in the 1990s oh yeah jar head
the hell i will you're a brain in a jar in a thousand years
i shall command space fleets across countless galaxies but
first i require more more Power!
You can be of...
You...
Best thing!
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Corny?
There is no Corny!
Cornelius?
No, no, no.
Too old.
So what do you actually want?
Fill me!
That is just plain creepy.
Is that Cornelius?
I was just talking to him.
He had a whole body with his brain.
What happened?
I swear to God he had a body with that.
I think it might be just...
I think it might be the crazy juice talking.
I swear to God.
I swear to God he had a body.
Did he not?
Had was the key word.
Okay, let's reset.
Whoa!
Why are your eyes up on the ceiling?
Who's up there?
Oh, no.
The funny gas is getting a bit too funny.
A bit too silly, guys.
Just maybe a little too silly.
with what blood oh with blood all right
get in there get in there
give me a sec i'm still trying to figure out how to get you
in there
oh my god we're not gonna make it i'm trying They're not
getting closer!
Oh, the glowing one!
Okay, get in there.
Oh, and there we go.
We figured it out.
There we go.
Two!
Alright.
Alright, three!
Don't worry!
You'll be one with the brain!
ain't too bad you get to have shared consciousness
you will oh never mind died a little too quickly you will be
a worthy sacrifice for the for the brain overlords oh wait
nice he just he spawned just there all right right here
all right last one there we go ain't too bad all united in
one you run into every day transfer the ink to the brain
chamber all right I go up time to transfer it so working
bottoms up ink for the ink god frontal lobe wisdom tooth
nostril oh I know that said but okay Okay, partial lobe.
I think it's working?
This mystery is getting crazy.
He's buffering?
We're on modem right now?
Much better?
Sorry about all that.
I'm right, stop.
How did you make that sound?
You're literally just the brain.
he's talking with his thoughts the brain is everything the
seat of the soul the engine of the invincible thing humble
three pounds of fat and water seasoned with carbohydrates
and just a pinch of salt mm-hmm now you sound like if you
give a brain enough ink you turn British please now come on
we've got some ruckus to rise oh great a talking burping gun
exactly what my life was missing oh what's this oh my god my
gun is brain wait how the fuck do i use this
oh shit oh it has a oh okay never mind ailey sucks
Oh, so it's like the brain juice.
I will say this gun is pretty ass.
I think maybe I just need to upgrade it, but it's not that
great.
If I use AoE, I might as well just use the acid gun.
It also has more ammo.
Oh, now I see the crazy flower.
Oh, it's a CC gun.
Oh, it's a stun.
I guess that makes more sense.
It'd be a stun gun.
All right, where do I go?
Okay, two milly.
That makes sense.
Oh.
What the fuck?
This area unlocked, so they might be...
Oh, secret!
Here's the other crazy mice.
Oh, shit!
Never mind.
What the fuck?
Who feeds you?
Who's feeding these mice?
All right, let's grab that.
You save.
I'm Millie, I'm here.
Hello, Jackie.
You old boy.
Oh, my God.
He's like 90% just full on me.
It's just a gun brain and a...
Well, excuse me.
Oh, my Lord, a talking gun.
This will be a load of fun.
I always think that is better.
What are you even doing here?
Jackie, Jacko, you poor sod.
Things around here are rather odd.
Look around and smell the place.
You wade through an unknown space.
What?
I really have no time for riddles.
There's a button there.
Oh, there is.
Oh, oh, I have no ammo.
Really, I'm sorry I killed your...
I'm sorry your dad's dead.
But I have important business to do here.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
Now I have ammo again.
Oh, fuck!
I got two and two kicking.
Alright.
What?
Where is she?
Nice thing.
Alright.
Yeah, notice that.
I'm just gonna start, I'm gonna use the...
I'm gonna use the shotgun.
Alright, never mind.
Ooh, I thought shotgun doesn't work on when it's long range.
Nice.
Another one.
Get them all out.
Or are the others?
There you are.
over here i'm not running away from you you're running away
from me
i don't think i need the cc gun when i could just kill them
all not gonna lie oh yeah my food's here oh
yeah oh i hear somebody on the other side oh i hear you
oops give me a sec reloading well give me a sec reloading
okay the sniper might have might have outpeaked me he might
have plus one frames guys the sniper is not fair he is plus
one he's plus one okay and watch this
Okay, never mind.
Okay, maybe...
There we go.
Maybe I should have done that instead.
Yeah, he has an unfair frame advantage right now.
He is also...
He has, like, two ping as well.
So, I demand that we play on Dallas servers so that we both
have equal ping.
There I am.
I swear to...
I think like the the shrews are tankier now you can usually
able to just headshot all of them and they just die But you
can't I can't even headshot them
Oh more of the silliest
Yeah, they tank more now All right, save
Oh, that's not a wall.
That's totally not a normal wall Or I caught a bug Is this
can't be real I think I'm gonna be sick.
Oh.
What?
That didn't hit them?
Oh, you're still here?
Oh.
Where could they spawn, though?
Oh, there it is.
Good old trusty acid gun.
I like how the skeletons...
The skeleton mice grows back their skin when I shoot acid on
them.
I think they forgot to animate that.
Bum, bum, bum, I love the soundtrack.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum.
Wait, what?
There we go, that should fully kill him.
Let me make sure I don't...
I'm not missing anything, though.
Not make sure no secret.
Oh!
Oh, I see you.
Oh, never mind.
I don't see you.
Alright.
I don't need a wall, right?
Oh, yeah.
Make sure we don't...
use shotgun now.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
Oh my
god, they're so fucking tanky for little guys.
Why are the bones made of titanium?
God damn titanium bones?
Where do I go from here?
What?
I hear someone below me.
He's like, he still comes down.
Oh, when I get you, when I get her, I can never escape the
bones.
Bone?
Oh, when I get her, she'll have it coming.
How do I get over there though?
There's nothing here.
Am I miss?
I must have missed something.
There must have been a sign.
Do I hover?
Maybe.
I'm gonna try.
Oh, I hover.
The hover mechanic is, like, so inconsistent, so I always
forget about it.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, oh.
Acid!
Oh, fuck, that's not acid!
Regular bullets!
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Is there someone next to me?
Oh, my God.
Who's shooting me?
I feel like I'm shot by 80 things!
Yeah.
There we go.
So many eyes.
They're all watching me.
I'm so self-conscious.
Don't look at me.
I'm trying my best.
I need to be.
here oh i knew it just because the other area also had
something
the fuck she lives those we used we did live them oh they're
all sucking an ink out of them
oh you're getting your ink blood nice
Made it.
Unlock the shortcut.
Now where am I?
Where am I?
Do I go zero?
No?
Oh my god, what shortcut is this?
The shortcut to where?
Oh, money, though.
Shortcut to where?
Where am I?
I think if I go...
You go to the area where there's pipes.
There it is.
There's the pipe.
It all looks the same.
It's so lost.
Wait, my food's here.
That makes no sense.
Wait, are you even real?
Millie, you're...
Finally, a spark of light.
Brace now for the final fight.
No more cheese fog in your brain.
All their efforts were in there.
What?
You're...
You're not really...
Oh no, it's the voices in my head.
No, Jack, I'm just your mind.
You were drifting, death and blind.
And my voices are a little girl?
There's so many.
I'm so confused.
To the lift, Jack.
You sure are dense sometimes.
Why are the voices a little girl that I just met?
So many questions.
No whole other area the whole other area I must explore She
broke the fourth wall
All right Pepper time who am I fighting oh oh all of these
guys
It's fine hydrate Don't drink your blood drink your blood
juice not tug it it's just confusing all right
open that lever oh
all right we gotta use the shotgun for this oh i keep
wanting i see a barrel i just want to kick it i just want to
keep kicking explosives i don't know why what do you know
fake millie knew what she was talking about for me like the
green goblin mask.
Like, kick it, duckie.
Kick it.
It's gonna be so funny.
Just do it.
Alright, up we go.
It calls to me.
That actually happened.
I might finally lose it.
No time to think.
My troops and thoughts.
They keep winning.
Alright, it should be a boss, but Whoa.
Holy moly.
Gun, you seen this?
Gun, are you...
Oh.
Huh.
I'm not tripping on cheese fumes no more.
Wait, so that's real?
What the hell happened here?
Wait, do I actually have a talking brain as a gun?
Okay, okay.
Is that a double jinx?
Do those stack?
Oh my god, it's...
It's Atman!
This is that thing!
In Atman!
It's the Atman portal!
all right this this is way above my pay grade all right i
think it has been way above his pay grade since uh level one
it's all forever man oh it's like oh it's all ink oh that's
trippy this reminds of the alice and wonderland level or
from the uh from the alice games this wasn't there before
right oh explore the unknown world oh i'm back in the
basement what i didn't get better back in the nut house did
i am i am i still high what's going on am i still tripping
balls right now
Okay, we go here.
Soon I am.
Okay.
Oh, is this where the magician is?
Look, it's all like magician references, though.
Like the...
Oh, sorry, look.
Because there was like the glass case, Taya.
Yeah, Houdini, so.
My friend, my magician friend.
Is this where he's hiding out?
Did he create his own fucking universe?
What?
It's just another bum you see on every corner.
Asking for change.
But we got to talking.
Turned out he came from true thicket.
Used to be a lawyer.
Once rich and respected.
Then the mouse came.
He got out, but a mouse bird.
We're a nuisance at best.
I felt for the guy, you know?
I really did.
Yeah, the glass cage would change.
Change.
I'm going to get my...
real quick guys i'll grab my food
hey i'm gonna start i'm just gonna eat take a little nipple
so i'll eat it later i'll eat it after i complete the levels
i want to take a little nipple also i want to drink my
lychee drink i ordered also maybe a little bit of a tapioca
Oh wait, that's my tiramisu.
Oops.
Oh, that tiramisu looked so...
That tiramisu looked so sad.
I...
Oh, that looked like a really sad tiramisu.
I looked at it and I was like, oh...
That looks very...
Very sludgy.
It just, it's like very melted and sluggie.
It looked really, really sad.
That's all I'll say.
It's not ready.
Just look at how sad it looked.
All right.
God.
A little bit of Takayaki.
All right, here we go.
Where do I have to go?
Oh, this way.
Huh.
What the fuck is shooting?
Oh, my God.
Oh, I could have shot the balloon.
I always forget the little platforms.
The little environment that kills.
Yay, money.
Dream money.
Do I get to keep the money even though it comes from the
Dreamiverse?
Oh, there he is.
See?
my friend Steve maybe wasn't Steve after all behold the
astonishing Steve vandal oh maybe he lives here to whoops so
that she can be with her we live his moments with her when
she was still alive yes
yeah see the robot fucker A three-time robot fucker.
The triple threat.
That's our boy Steve.
So what now?
What the fuck?
The robot what?
Yeah, you heard me say it.
Good old Steve.
Created three robots for his dead girlfriend.
Yeah, the clankers fan.
You know, seeds.
Oh, I swear to God.
If I have to turn on a lever again, I swear to God.
Every time I pick up a goddamn barrel.
There's something I'm missing.
What?
Why did it go backwards?
Oh, it went up.
That's why.
Oh, well, oh, of course this is how it works.
Where's the sniper, though?
Oh, no.
There we go.
Yeah, this is such...
This is better CC.
That's better CC than the brain juice.
Alright, I got that.
Is there another one?
Another target for me?
What did I do?
Oh my bathtub car of course so obvious so so fucking obvious
the bathtub car capital I didn't think of it first oh
oh that's just like you're telling me to go into the tunnel
guys so inviting they're so welcoming into the the ink I
think that's what they're trying to say, right?
Like, come!
It's so fun!
It's so fun there, in there.
Yeah, come into the death hole, guys!
Where all your dreams come true!
Ah, yes!
have a great time in the death pit even these little hell
spawn and knocking back cheese real classy fellas
oh what what the fuck are devils now oh my god hell is real
hell is real where is he
get out of here
Okay, so Steve, Doug, not only did hope you enjoy the Doom
reference, oh, is this for, based off, oh, Mouse Bird
Herald, 66666, oh, they're in the future, wow, hell is in
the future, I wonder if they have iPhones right now, wait,
is Doug keep playing, Doom, I'm gonna Super Chat, thank you,
thank you, Steve, aren't you alright, aren't you not
satisfied?
You made three robot wives, and then you also want to dig a
tunnel to hell?
Steve!
Oh, that trumpet, you sweet, sweet angel of death.
He'll never be satisfied.
What more do you want, Steve?
A mad cat have obvious.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
It's all devils.
It continues through hell.
Oh, goodbye.
Whoa, whoa, I made it.
Whoa, I made it.
Okay, I have one HP, though.
Wait, what?
I just have to wait.
Okay, I just had, okay, I am, I'll have cheese.
I need to remember, I also have my own pair of cheese.
Are you ready with these guys?
You do get a lot tankier, the further I get progress.
Oh my, my.
Oh.
Sure takes the cake.
Oh, then, surely nothing bad.
Oh, my God, is that a chainsaw?
Oh, God.
Now we're gaming.
Okay, I need to make sure they come to me first If I can use
my goddamn chainsaw.
Where are they?
Where are all of them?
Oh,
wait, I have an alternate.
Bye.
Oh, wait, I'm dead.
I need my cheese.
Okay, chainsaw might not be as effective.
as you think it is.
Alright, the chainsaw is not as cool as you think it is,
guys.
My good old reliable gun might be more efficient.
Who would have thought?
Gun is always better.
Couple shoddy for immersion.
Okay, at least these guys are still weak as hell.
Okay.
We're good.
Is there anything else here?
We need as much HP as we can get.
In armor, too.
But you...
That looks so cool.
Where's my Resident Evil chainsaw?
I think I got everything.
I have to be sure.
Efficient?
Sure.
But more fun?
Yeah, but is it as...
more fun than chainsaw i don't think i even see you with
chainsaw
oh whoa who shot me oh my god this guy
that was illegal
you gotta warn me before you shoot it's basic manners
Okay, blow the final Hellhorn.
Oh, there he is.
And you are heard footsteps slowly walking up to me.
It's shooting 101!
Elsa, play EM1M1D.
Rector, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, where is he?
Where's the last guy?
Oh.
There we go.
Where is the last horn?
Hello?
I'm gonna see my...
Oh, oh, he's walking back and forth.
It is...
Where is he going?
What?
Oh!
Like, that's not a horn!
Silly brush!
Oh, shit!
It's windy!
Steamboat windy!
I guess that would... I guess that also...
Copyright expired.
All right, get up.
gamers don't look left right or up or down we just look
straight ahead continue through hell that's what we're gonna
do about oh shit that's what he's gonna do about it
true gamer way
how that's how that's nice he chased me all the way up here
Steve thank you buddy Steve, what are you doing here?
The robust can't be that good.
Better watch it, getting hammered in-house.
Oh, what?
What killed me?
What?
Did I have a heart attack in hell?
It is that good.
Oh my god, there was a hammer.
I didn't even realize there was a hammer.
Oh my
god, they killed him all over again, too.
That's the worst part.
Alright, continue through hell.
Alright, where's that hammer?
Duff!
Yeah, I can respawn.
Where was the hammer?
Oh my god, there it is.
There was the hammer.
I want you to get in the hammered in-house.
Sounds like a headache.
Okay.
Alright.
Dodge.
God, the things I do for Steve.
Things I do.
He is a million magician, though.
Damn it.
Ran off again.
oh oh where did he run death by lack of rope what where am i
what oh my god it's fucking what is that game called it's pt
oh my god oh no no no no no no that definitely definitely
was not my car
here oh okay I don't need any of these don't lose him I
don't even know where he is oh fuck okay
oh hey I like that that's cute Brian this seems like an
arena seems like arena like where
is he Oh, I killed them all.
I like that.
I like the little things.
The fact that the banjo plays when you touch it.
Very cute.
A little extra touch.
Alright, pass through time.
What?
Here's a war?
Oh my god.
What kind of fucking world did he create?
Alright, time to...
Jump on gears.
I can't believe gears are war.
It's from the 1930s.
Oh my god, the fire spread that far.
This is definitely not OSHA approved.
Not a very safe workplace, Steve.
Oh no, now we're at the robot part of his mind.
Oh, no.
Now we're on the freakier side.
The place where Steve doesn't want anyone to know.
We're getting closer.
It's gonna get freaky now.
We're in his private freak chambers.
Let me see what it does.
There's still one more somewhere.
Oh, I knew it.
Oh, you were scared.
I got you.
That's right.
You can't escape from me even in Steve's mind.
I'm always living rent-free.
What did I open?
Is that area?
What's over here?
Oh, secret.
Yeah, I was going to say.
I've never seen this area before.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
Where am I?
Oh?
How did I get here?
I didn't...
Oh, whoa!
Oh, that's close.
Okay, save.
For a crazy house, this place is oddly organized.
and they got those Steve placed those those bombs next to
those snipers thanks Steve convenient place barrels nice of
him to do that for me it's like how do I get up there though
oh the gears it's always the gears
Eh?
Oh, here.
I was like, who's shooting me?
This.
Or that is actually not fair.
They have the high ground.
There you go.
See, even when you're cheating, I win.
Nah, there's no sniper rifles.
I think, oh wait, no, there's, I'm still missing two more
guns.
So maybe a sniper comes in here.
And if only I saw the ice barrel earlier.
And...
Oops.
I mean, that still works.
Sir, you have a shotgun that's not gonna hit me.
Oh, shit, that might hit me, though.
Unless...
Oh!
Perfect strat!
You go to the...
the left and then go to the right.
They'll never expect this straight pattern.
They'll die eventually.
There we go.
I took a couple of shots.
Alright.
Steve, are you here?
Whoa!
Steve!
Steve?
It's just rude Steve this is real hell look.
I know you miss it Steve.
It's me Jack.
We gotta move on Steve Gotta live your life.
She would have want that The goal is to be unified.
Okay.
It's hard equals hard You ain't taking me alive crook Damn
He's really lost his marbles.
Oh, he really has to be crazy right now
What?
What card did he pull out?
Oh, spade.
Okay.
I got it.
Steve!
We're bussy can't be that good, Steve!
Please, Steve!
There is plenty of fun.
Fish is in the sea!
I totally can't!
Well, guys, chat.
We're musty.
Like, what card do you... Okay, I wasn't...
Okay, heart.
There we go.
Steve is in need.
We're musty was so good.
he created in the whole alternate universe for her.
And then he went absolutely crazy.
A tale as old as time.
We gotta save him, Toki!
Oh!
Whoops!
I was like...
I got to move to the left.
Creating a whole world.
Because all you could do is think of her
No, it's just two more cards left.
Oh, never mind
All right
Came so crazy You literally created three robots by the way
Three robots in a whole alternate universe Oh, now you're
calm great good that was annoying are you sure steve are you
sure i think calm might not be the right word for how you're
feeling steve this might be your definition of calm but i
don't think that is the medical term for what you're doing
right now and now you're calm met in the medical definition
we might need to see a specialist for you steve Come on,
he's just pent up.
Hey, Jack.
Oh, no, don't you hijack me.
The hoops I had to jump through just to get to you.
To hell and back, right?
Well, the back part's still up in the air.
So, what the hell are you doing here?
What the hell are you doing here?
That tried to kill me five minutes ago the way i'm solving a
missing magician case that somehow dumped me into a mess of
angry mice missing shrews and mad scientists yeah i hear you
but now you're here it's time to move on what do you mean
you mean like in minecraft towards the light see heavens no
move your tail out of here before something worse finds you
i mean i don't know i made this far sure but jack i'm hiding
here you showing up kind of ruins the whole hideout part get
me ah so the vaudeville drama wasn't just some flashy
vanishing act you were covering your tracks not bad the
cheese jug bit much though don't you think come on you know
me i always had a thing for dramatic exits and with the big
mouse party and the mob on my tail i didn't have a lot of
options yeah somehow you never do look jack i tried going
legit i really sort of did but then betty my beloved
assistant rest her soul introduced me to von hartzer old
world professor or the professor if you prefer turns out we
had a shared interest shared interest in what see this place
the unknown oh my god i've been chasing it ever since the
war or whoops i i died in my breath even invited a cult to
help i can't get rid of the bastards now always came up
short till i figured out what i was missing he's still
talking a cat taboo the lifeblood of our world crazy stuff
powerful wait we made it is it doesn't come easy ink is
blood i needed a lot of it so when see professor showed up
with research of his own i figured why not team up huh i
provide funds resources give him whatever he needs to finish
the portal in my lab but the ink the most crucial ingredient
came from the shrews huh that's what the shrews were for i
always knew you were a cold bastard but this No, no, no you
you got it wrong.
Steve you were racist the entire time.
I told him about the shortage and he figured the shrews Uh,
they have the perfect ink ratio Steve he called it.
I should have known I thought it was a joke at first when we
were in war, you know, because we're dying all that shit.
I should have known Shrews like literally squeezing them
dry.
I, I couldn't.
Well, I leave the life you built.
He was juicing the shrews!
I couldn't, but...
When some mass psycho starts circling and the big mouse
party gets involved, well...
They don't do friendly tea parties, let me tell you.
So you ran.
Only logical choice.
Disappear where no one dares follow.
Lay low till things blow over.
But now...
I'm not so sure it'll ever be over.
Well, it ain't, because those eggheads are rebuilding the
portal at the curdsville nut house god damn shrewd juice a
little bit the nut house son of a I I figured but I hoped
damn it this is bad Jack you have to go back not that I
don't enjoy your company but someone's got to put a stop to
this you have to find one heart sir and well blow whatever
floats as you boot to smithereens promise me that you know
Steve this is your mess not your first either but I was kind
of planning on it anyway so yeah sure fine i'll do it ah see
between you me and cornelius you're always the one with a
functioning moral compass thanks jack so this doesn't
explain why now what about you why he did the whole car
thing stuff to me forever time doesn't tick by the same as
in our reality i'm surprised you aren't asking a million
questions about this place state we fought in the trenches i
gunned my way through mad scientist and crooked cops.
At this point, I don't got the energy to be surprised.
So why the fuck was he trying to kill me with the fucking
card tricks?
That doesn't explain anything.
Sheesh.
Just step through the mirror, Jack.
Oh, and, uh...
I don't know.
Maybe he's just crazy or something.
He was high on that true juice.
Alright.
Now that he finished monologuing, I can fix it.
Give me a sec.
I'm booting it back up.
Whoa, whoa.
It's called a showmanship.
He's just being a little dramatic, you know?
A little party game.
He's oh, so lonely in this world.
No, he don't understand.
He's lonely.
He's just so lonely right now.
you could just you know talk to me instead instead of like
taking me to hell seeing Steve again wasn't the clean break
I wanted cuz he was still dirty still a bastard still that
cynical son of her but he was my war buddy and he wasn't
dead part of me hated that I felt relief maybe he changed
maybe maybe he finally grew a conscience or maybe I'm a fool
growing yet another soft spot maybe in the end we're all
just cards and some rich man's machine grinding away until
we break
all right well now we know what they're doing with the
shrews one is gonna think I'm nuts no matter how I slice
yank is shrews well give her the whole scoop all right see
if there's any comic strips we're missing okay so i slipped
out you know to grab a crumb maybe a girl's cheese no one
see me and then i met him oh this is when he used the the
homeless man's dead body bad boy eats bad book it chronicles
that 11 year old floors upset stomach was caused by little
rats appetite or estro esoteric literature literally by time
this diagnosis was made Floyd had child that entire volume
platter team musos except the covers and two parishes on
layering realities his father when asked admitted sure he
did sometimes philosophy cheese louise but they're building
the shoes oh sorry about that uh systemic screwing you just
don't know what you're talking about no you don't you're
young you're full of fire and it's easy to claim to have it
all figured out but you don't know half as much as you think
you do oh I don't no kiddo you don't believe it or not I was
more or less your age when they shipped us off to war I
thought we were fighting for something real turns out it was
just smoke gas and lies wrapped in flags and it broke us but
we came home anyway Yay, PTSD!
Oh no, don't tell me you've got all disillusioned vet on me.
You've got a mouth on you, kid.
I've been told.
We believed, Tam.
And I still do.
Some days.
That we can fix things.
Make it better.
Otherwise, why do we keep going, huh?
Why keep getting back up every time the world knocks me on
my ass?
I know, Jack.
That's why I couldn't hate you for long.
Even when I wanted to.
You're one of the good ones.
What does that even mean?
A little confused sometimes.
When people say you're one of the good ones, that implies
something.
What does she mean by that?
Kind of mean that deals massive damage on Headshot.
Okay, wait, that's actually pretty good.
You're just, you're one of the good ones, Doki.
What do you mean by that?
Dami, what do you mean?
What do you mean I'm one of the good ones?
Yeah
I Let's see we gotta tell Wanda about the latest scoop You
know, just one of the good ones Jack what do you mean you
people you look like you just saw a ghost I did sort of I
found him Steve Bandle alive and weird.
Oh, really?
do tell you'll never believe me jack i once printed your
story about a rat burglar who swore a tiny mushroom alien on
his head was steering him like a meat puppet my tolerance
for nonsense is limitless so where was bandel hold up i
don't know i i mean really i can't wrap my head around what
i saw it's it was just a little universe he created after
his girlfriend died you know just the usual tricks but yeah
I went through hell and back to get to him so what he staged
his own abduction why what's the angle he um well look
Steve's always been about the money but lately he's
developed a little side hobby French science occult stuff
that got him tangled in a series of deeply questionable
events like well shrewd trafficking morbid science projects
the real epitome of ethics he didn't do it all on his own
right no that's the kicker he got involved with some old
world eggheads led by someone who goes by the you know nam
de guerre z professor i hear they got in cahoots through one
betty lynch wait the dead actress wasn't quite dead back
then and steve in all his wisdom gave those brainiacs full
access to his work but when things took a sharp left
Like a pussy.
Like a mob and whoever fuels this scientific circus.
And he's not exactly chatty about the details.
Tell me you at least slap some cuffs on him.
I don't think he's into that.
Besides, he's different.
Not all for the better, but I don't think he's the bad guy
here.
More like a guy who got in way too deep and realized too
late.
And wherever he is now, he's only dangerous to himself.
Oh, that's a bit of an anticlimactic ending to a promising
case.
Yep.
He begged me to burn this whole thing to the ground, to blow
whatever floats Z Professor's U-Boot or something.
Gave me nothing substantial, though, and damn, I do hate
leaving cases dead in the water.
Wait, wait, wait.
Water.
U-Boot.
old world you know there's been talk at the herald about a
strange submarine surfacing at the docks i was gonna run a
piece on it but it deflated real soon it's got old world
markings you think that wanda you beautiful genius you never
disappoint i gotta hurry to the docks before z professor
goes on the submarine all right we gotta go fucking catch
him before we can catch him we do have another there is
another area to go to don't words, the professor can wait.
We do it for a homie?
That's a bro.
Look, a lot of stuff happens in the war.
Okay, guys.
Like, when you're drafting the war, it gets very, very, very
lonely.
We take, they take turns.
Pros bros gotta do what bros gotta do they were punk mates
why else do you think those three were very very close a
piece of my rice fell in between not in between not in the
keyboard but i fell in between my keys so i have to like
blew off my chopsticks so i gotta get that out of here
that out of here real quick i don't want to it actually fall
between into my keyboard right there you go whoo yes all
right nice i got it out great nice all right next area
okay there's the submarine i want to go over here i don't
remember what this area was for oh it's where she
disappeared is where the other actress disappeared The one
that killed the other guy, that killed Millie's dad.
This is where she ran up to.
I remember now.
I know, it's very important to stop the professor.
Which made me sure the mob was close.
Are you running your fanfic, don't you?
Mr. Broken Bunny, you're a super chat.
Thank you.
Reggie, they're here.
Every tongue, dick, and Reggie.
Don't you sherry me, you simpleton!
They came!
The whole lot!
Do something!
Oh shit.
Very inconvenient that it was broadcast.
Not very stealthy of them.
Not very incognito.
I'm actually gonna kill the guy with the gun first instead
of the dog.
Oh!
Dad!
Don't look!
I didn't!
I didn't do anything!
Don't look!
Wow, he got mad.
He heard that.
Well, look who it is.
Oh, it's a pile technique.
See me again, shore is shooting.
What's got you all fired up now, man?
I've got to get in the control room, pronto.
Ooh, no, no, no, no, no.
easy amico gotta flip them switches first switches different
type this is the tinsel brothers studio you can't just waltz
in everywhere like that you need switches stitches stinky
britches well the case is blown then my pants are patched
and shamefully clean oh switches need no stitches they need
just a little sniffing around the corner easy to spot if you
stay sharp sharp I can do Don't worry, Dad, you're one of
the good ones.
Don't worry.
Hey.
He wants my food.
He knows I'm eating.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, it's some moving pictures.
Oh, it's tornado scene.
Filming a tornado scene.
Oh!
It's Wizard of- Whoa!
What are the colors?
It's- Oh my god,
colors!
Is that...
Color team, it is the Wizard of Oz!
Is that blue?
I've never seen these colors before!
Call the bodyguards now!
Oh my god!
Is this what people call blue?
What the fuck?
Witchcraft!
This is most crap.
That's green.
No, this is yellow.
We all know grass has always been yellow.
Oh, that's nice.
That's a nice reference, though, to Wizard of Oz.
I was like, oh, hey, it's the tornado.
Oh, no, back to real reality now.
Back to depression.
Oh, it's Beauty and the Beast.
Touch the rose.
Now it's Beauty and the Beast.
In 1930s?
I'm sorry.
a cactus all right since it once been they go here i'm gonna
check up top just in case yeah i knew it damn the organist
is going crazy right now he's being paid like five cents per
hour
yeah but has there been like beauty and the beast adaptation
before disney I've not seen one before.
Unless, like, Disney just overtaken everything related to
Beauty and the Beast that people don't remember the other
versions.
A butt?
Oh, really?
I did not know that.
Whoops.
Oh, nope.
Maybe...
Oh, I might have accidentally shot something I shouldn't
have shot.
Oh, that's fine.
It's fine.
It just conveniently stops there.
That's all right.
The insurance will cover it for sure, maybe.
I'm pretty sure the insurance will cover it.
Here they are, they are creating an organ as an instrument?
You're literally playing a building.
Thank you for the super chat, Gordon.
Thank you.
That's crazy.
I assume it takes a lot of skill to play on the organ.
Because of all the buttons and everything.
Oh My god, Beethoven Whoa, where did he come from this tiny
guy come from?
Yeah, nice Oh, is it maintaining it's hard
The perfect sound for murder.
Oh, there's the vent.
Is that really a secret here?
How do I do this?
Oh, like this.
This.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, here.
Wait, back here?
Why was I here anyway?
What the fuck?
What?
No, it just wouldn't make me go backwards.
Alright.
Why is this?
Oh my god, it could have...
It could have just...
Okay, whatever.
Wait, burn the books?
Oh!
Wait, can I burn that?
I didn't even notice.
Oh, I got it.
can oh nice who cares about reading yeah fuck reading it's
like it's already open there why do you have to make another
entrance it's just added like 800 instructions they're like
you didn't use the right solution Teacher's like, you get
the answer and teacher's like, that was not the...
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Don't you hate that, though?
When you get the answer and teacher was like, um, you didn't
do it the way I want you to do it.
Whoops.
Okay, there was a wall to my right.
I was trying to dash.
Yeah, that's not the process I taught you.
Yeah,
I actually went...
Was he like...
Didn't he?
We're just gonna sit over here real quick.
Oh, fuck, okay, whoops!
Whoa, shit!
We're loading!
Alright, he's almost dead.
That's what's doing crazy worth.
Alright, get out of here.
Wait, you're just...
Oh, you're two shrews and a trench coat!
Here's where I get my stuff.
Oh my god, and they get paid half the price over a regular
mouse.
You know it.
Oh, hey.
I find a second switch.
I mean, am I even supposed to be here?
Wait, how do I get here?
Oh, come on!
It's right there!
Let me cheese!
Aw, wouldn't let me cheese.
They're like, no, no, no.
That's not how we want you to get to this area.
Can't believe it, speedrunners in shambles.
What?
What the?
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh my god, bugged it out.
What?
What the fuck?
Did I just not take my meds?
Sorry, the meds were off for like 0.1 second there.
Hey, it's my office.
Yeah, wait, what the heck?
The reports outline the requirements for a good movie that
tackles various social usages, tells people what to think
and how to act, and eventually moves the whole world and
civilization towards a brighter future.
A small hammer and pendant states that tinsel rose, still
does not pay extras, and forces directors shooting off 17,
but 19 movies per day.
You think I'm asking him will be all about exactly.
Lolly, thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I didn't even create in my office.
That's weird.
That's fucking weird.
Hope I'm not one of them men from up the stairs.
Alright, now we're back in the swamps.
Yeah.
Where are they coming out of?
Nice, we got the lab.
We got some schematics.
What is this a parody of?
What, reloading?
Oh, is this a horror movie?
Oh, it's the...
It's the one about the...
The swamp mouse.
okay that is not it's not about the swap mouse i don't know
anymore i don't know what that's referencing is it alice of
wonderland i just see tea party in his room
shrek the old shrek from the 1930s
is it creature from the blacklet wound why is there why is
there a tea party here
Nice.
Got to reload, thank God.
Cuphead finger guns.
That's how they give me all that ammo and all, and then
finger guns.
They're like, alright, she's gonna fight her way out of
here.
It's like, you know what?
No, finger guns.
Make this easier for us.
For all of us.
Alright, I'll go this way.
Oh.
Why don't I go up here?
What the fuck?
I see the coin!
Oh my god, it's just tempting me.
Can't believe you do this to me.
It's just sitting there.
Asking me to take it.
You can't do this to me!
Oh shoot the rope.
Oh, okay, that makes me...
Alright, there you go.
Figured it out.
It is here.
Oh, back in color.
Oh!
Okay.
Ding, ding, ding.
Where can they show up?
It's just like a tight corridor.
I get him?
But I got him.
Alright, nice.
Yeah, fuck it.
That's right.
bit of acid wouldn't hurt anybody well it wouldn't hurt me
oh is this uh what's that book about racism surprisingly a
lot of them but you know that book that got banned from
school y'all be specific don't keep oh no this is alice in
wonderland never mind there is alice in wonderland i was
thinking about the to kill a mockingbird i was thinking
about that i the judge and jury find you guilty of all
crimes how to kill a mockingbird you're kind of a long list
dude yeah be more specific or are you guilty oh judge patel
for stealing the innocence of an art we sentence you to die
slowly what did i do
Um, I didn't consent to that.
Wait, them slowly hurt me.
Who's the one committing crime right now?
Because it doesn't look like...
Oh, shit.
Oh, she's proud of this, too.
That would make sense, actually.
That makes sense.
Oh, that's...
Nice.
Okay, the brain juice goes through barriers.
Oh, no more brain juice.
Oh, fuck this.
Alright, that makes more sense now, though, knowing that.
Boop.
I wonder if they keep responding, though.
What if I just kill all of them?
They do.
responding.
Good news!
They do keep on responding.
Well, not great news for me.
Do I just leave like...
I'm just gonna take that.
There we go.
Good news for her.
All right, that's easy.
Now that I know they just keep responding.
all on here.
Alright, is that everything?
Alright, grab the armor.
Bye.
Goodbye, man.
Go back.
Why?
Honestly, Reggie, you are as dry as the ship biscuit after a
very long voyage.
I like biscuits, Viv.
What's wrong with that?
What's wrong with that, Viv?
Oh, we're here now.
All right, switch time.
We're at a turn.
All right.
How are you still alive?
Just stop pepper now.
So, uh, uh, uh, oh, I don't just need a weird change of
scenery.
How will I stop him?
Only the only thing I have have is my gun.
How do we do it?
Where is he?
Oh, shit.
There he is.
No, I'd fuck it.
I'm like, where's the acid?
There we go.
Good old acid.
Where is he?
There he is.
I'm sure he's a mouse?
Feels very rabbit to give you.
Oh, I found a secret!
Let's go!
Oh, fuck!
I'm sorry, let's just beam them.
Mind control them.
Oh, reload.
Alright, finish mind controlling.
Oh.
No more.
That should be all of them.
Where are you?
Where did he go?
And now there's dogs.
Oh, fuck!
Alright.
We gotta find him.
Where is he going?
There he is.
There's no way you're still shooting, buddy.
I am.
Holy shit, he's so tanky.
This guy is actually so fucking tanky.
Is
he acid?
There's no way there's type advantages in this mouse PI
game.
I refuse to believe that.
Doki, it's because he's...
It's because he's bug type, Doki.
It's because he's from Hollywood.
He's so used to taking all the acid.
Is that it?
I get it?
He's from Hollywood.
That's why acid is ineffective.
Alright, but that's the case.
I'm just gonna shotgun this guy.
See that changes anything
Guys, I don't think shotgun changes anything Shotgun might
not be changing anything
Bombs away
I don't know if those fires hurt me See, I'm concerned
about.
Oh, yeah, no, they definitely hurt me.
No, I found out they hurt me, guys.
Oh.
Okay.
Big guys out of the way.
Grab more HP.
Oh, no.
Nice.
Okay, that should be the last one.
We could keep shooting for an hour, and neither of us would
win.
Crazy, that fire hurts, guys.
I know.
Who could have saw this?
Who would have known?
What?
Wait, why did I say that?
Why did I agree to that?
But he's still holding a gun.
Oh.
Wait, he added his HP back?
Okay.
all right that's fucking right that's right oh shit yeah
that's right what are you gonna do now huh oh yeah that's
right the left right back up the left right shimmy wait wait
a minute wait a minute that's cheating
that's fucking cheating he set the fire he fucking blew He
set the fucking ground on fire!
That's illegal!
She's bobbing and weaving.
This scene's already a disaster.
Are you fucking kidding me?
No!
Oh my god.
It's all the way back to...
That's crazy.
I'm so sad.
They actually...
are making me do this all the way back.
I have to start from phase one.
Only because he started playing dirty.
He played dirty.
That is insane.
I should not have even lost that fight.
I was winning.
You expected honor, Doki.
He was the one that said, fist only.
Final destination.
Okay.
No items.
Did he actually got me?
Oh, he got me.
Fuck, I thought I would.
And you believe them.
That's final destination.
No items, fist only.
Oh god,
I hate the fucking...
Come on, look at me, look at me!
I grab this.
Hello!
Hello, I'm back!
It is so annoying!
I should have never updated my drivers!
Oh my god!
The one, to the guys, like, it's not the drive.
I've never had a stream crash.
If you guys look through all my old streams, we've never had
a stream crash for the longest time.
Like, you know, where, like, I crash in the middle, like,
every, like, my OBS crashes and everything.
I haven't had that in a long time.
Never since I updated it.
Ever since I updated the drivers during the Pragmatas
stream, have been like crashing like like
back-to-back-to-back and stuff yeah
yeah so I know it has to do with the driver update because
yeah ever since the update has been like once a stream to
the guy that was like it's not your driver update it's
literally the driver update because we never it was pragmato
when we kept having pragmato would just crash but I've never
any other game that was just crashing non-stop and it like
that would just keep crashing um and it was just pragmatic
that was just crashing non-stop and then like but it never
crashed my stream with my old drivers um with my old drivers
when we're playing pragmatic uh yeah but when we played
mouse pi before we know we're crashing like that we weren't
crashing like that Yeah.
And so it's like, it's been really annoying that it keeps
happening.
I don't know if the driver update like bricked something in
my, uh, bricked something in my, in my GPU, but it's been so
fucking annoying that's happening every, every stream now.
Yeah, I wrote back the drivers to this morning.
When we were doing the, when we're playing, we're doing the
inconvenient stream.
we rolled it back um we rolled it back a bit um to I don't
remember which one uh oh it's so frustrating because like I
have to fix it I have to no it could be the rollback of the
driver though it could be the rollback of the driver because
I haven't I might have to roll it back even more.
It update fucked up my GPU.
It fucked up.
It fucked up something on my PC.
Because, um, yeah, I use DDU.
Because I haven't, um, I haven't had any issues.
Until, until we had to update the drivers.
And then now I'm crashing my stream.
Like my, my stream, my OBS.
is crashing now too like the encode is not like it would be
like oh something like everything would just shut down um so
I know it's not nothing I know it has something to the
drivers because we never had this these instances we've
never had instances where we haven't had any major PC issues
for so long until the Pragmata stream where I wanted to
finish Pragmata and we couldn't get past that one stage on
the fucking train we couldn't pass that one stage um and
then but then it was only pragmata that was crashing so but
then the moment i updated the drivers it was now my obs
crashing too so i'm gonna check the event longer viewer i do
have an event viewer let me see i do i restart my pc every
day i i turn off my pc every day after i'm done using it
Let's see.
I'm going to give you a little 30 second time because you're
getting a little too heated.
I'm going to give you a 10 second.
I'm going to give you a 10 second in the corner because
you're getting a little too heated.
I do restart and jump my PC.
You're getting a little too heated, bro.
Calm down.
This is my PC.
Come on.
Alright.
Alright, what was I going to say?
Yeah, go to the bone zone.
Yeah, sit in the bone zone for a little bit, bro.
anyway i'm looking at my event viewer right now i just want
to finish mouse bi that's all i want to know i'm not about
to do this i'm about to do this it's been so long
it's been so long since i've had i thought we made it guys i
thought we made it out of the hole i was like everything's
great i have a 50 90 now i'm a fucking Beefy CPU?
Ah, life is great.
Surely not...
No issues whatsoever for so long.
Everything's wonderful.
I thought we were past this.
I thought it was finally over.
We did it.
You can't have shit.
I can't have nothing.
Oh, maybe it is over here.
I'm going to open the door.
I don't want to turn the aircon too much because dad's
outside sleeping.
So I'm just going to open the door and let cool air in.
Um.
Anyway.
I get a shot at graded college.
Of course, Juan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congratulations on graduating college.
You made it through the canvas hostage situation.
I'm proud of you.
You made it.
You don't have to worry about canvas being held hostage.
You know the worst part?
I have to do that stupid fucking level all over again.
That's the worst part.
It's not the thing is, my PC's okay in a way where it's,
doesn't shut down it just black screens and then comes back
it's just all my applications crashes so it's not just a
mouse game it's like mouse vtube studio v bridger and obs
being like we can't we can't stream right now like it was
like the encoder full or something um encoder errors thing
wasn't a blue screen or anything.
Yeah.
So it was an OBS thing.
I looked it up and it was just encoder full.
I looked it up before.
It says like encoder is... Yeah, it's just like, oh, encoder
is full.
So we can't record right now.
And then I just have to restart OBS.
And so,
because I looked up the OBS error thing, and that's what it
gives me.
It is tilting, because, like I said, I wish I didn't update
my drivers.
My old driver served me well.
It served me well.
Why did I betray it?
Why?
Why did I leave you?
My price of finishing for nine.
He treated me so well.
All these months.
Do you remember the version you had before?
The one in July, 2025.
That's the one version I remember.
Oh my god, you have to roll back again.
I really don't want to roll back again.
I remember how to view the event log.
event uh event viewer on windows i really don't remember
it's been like i said it's been so long it's been like a
full year since i got a 50 90.
oh
it didn't want to change it was like do we try and risk it
again do we risk and keep going I just keep my door open and
hope for the best
I'm on event no no no I'm already going through PC crashes I
don't know if I have to take it to the PC place to fix it
that's the thing oh
do we yamba do we yamba maybe if the door open it'll feel
better
maybe the door open the pc would would feel better about
itself
i do when my friends installed it um this is a setup monitor
when my friends installed it for my no that's not it when
just to like look through stuff to help me fix things oh my
god i have to fight that stupid boss again That's the worst
part.
I see that goddamn stupid boss again.
I didn't, I've never, I've had game crashes.
But never OBS crash.
Very, never, never not.
I had a full OBS crash.
But now it's like every stream, which is very frustrating.
I was like, you know, I want to fucking...
um you
know never never had like full-on stream crashes itself
oh at least i can eat it let me eat guys let me i don't
think there's something i always i always try i always think
of something
uh yeah but the fact that even like you know vampire
crawlers
Vapy crawlers also crashed, right?
Oh, I'm getting low.
Um, what's it called?
Chirashu?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't remember.
It feels like every...
No, it did!
It did.
Remember?
The game crashed.
stream didn't crash, but the game crashed.
Because I was like, because I was drawing cards, and then
suddenly the game crashed.
Yeah.
It's already something.
Can you shake off?
Why the fuck?
I thought I turned that off already.
Oh, man.
That's frustrating, though.
I was so...
I was... I was ready to finish this game, too.
Alright, if we crash again, I will have to call it.
We finished this game another time.
Because, like, I gotta fix the PC thing.
Yeah, that's very frustrating.
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna roll it back again right now.
Um...
Only because...
I don't know if it's gonna fix it.
I'd rather fix it after this stream.
Yeah.
I have my doors open.
I'm going to turn up the air conditioning a little bit more.
I don't like turning the air conditioning up too much
because dad's outside and obviously I don't want it to be
too cold outside for him.
So I try not to turn it up too high.
I'm going to turn it.
I have to do it.
But I'm going to sleep outside.
Yeah.
Oh.
yo the chibi was just a precaution for frog bottom yeah let
me finish my food guys finish my food with jazz play in the
background i think i'm just cursed it doesn't matter i
didn't want to get if when i get dual pc set up they will i
will find a way i'll find the world will find a way to still
give me tech issues I don't even before Corpo I was always
having issues I every every PC every time there will always
be a way I will always find a way yeah double the PC double
the tech issues
I'll have one of my friends look through my stuff To figure
it out But I also I might do like a bonus stream Have
deserved money Treat yourself at all Guys I get a super chat
Don't worry I have my sad looking tiramisu Like let me take
a picture of the tiramisu I almost forgot about it It looks
so sad I was like Yeah I can't wait for my tiramisu And it
came out like super sad It looks like super sad super soggy
and like it looks like I need to put it out like outside in
the pasture and just end its life but it's just like at
least in my suffering it looks so sad like it's just begging
for me to shoot it out back here it's a very depressed
looking depressed looking tiramisu
oh shit I forgot about this All right, I got a message that
someone messaged me and they were like bumping this.
I was like, oh, fuck, I forgot this thing.
I'll do that later.
All right, look at my sad tiramisu, guys.
It's so depressing.
Oh, that is so sad.
That is so depressing.
I told you it looked like it looked like I wouldn't even
want to stop existing in the world.
I'm having this breaks with my heart.
He's also having an equally bad day.
it's tiramisu it's like tiramisu no it's just sad even dad
was like yeah it's so sad looking tiramisu all right i'm
gonna i'm definitely he's getting more brady lately i don't
know why i'm not even why lately the last couple of days
he's been very very very bratty like when I'm streaming and
I don't know why right now I don't know what's causing it so
I might have to take him to a dog trainer to see what to do
I pay you to take that off the screen it's making me sad I
even think it was super chat thank you thank you I told you
I told you when I got it I was like damn that's a sad
looking tear of me Sue oh my god I was looking forward to
I would have done it from the same restaurant.
Maybe dad or judge.
It helps with what my fucking status?
Do you hear me too?
A depressed dessert.
But yeah.
But I've been crashes again.
I've been stream crashes.
Again.
I'm gonna call it.
I can't have, I don't think I can have an during stream with
it.
The thing is Tomodachi life was fine because it was running
because like Tomodachi life was fine because we were
streaming the you know we were just streaming me on top of
the game but like mouse PI vampire crawlers progmata all of
it all three of them been like pretty annoying to deal with
yeah so
like if it happens again today we're gonna call it here i'm
gonna talk to my friends to look over what's it called like
you know like those things where they control your pc i
forgot what the program is but that's what they did last
time um they like controlled my pc and then like look
through wrong um and then remote viewer yeah yeah they
remote viewer in my stuff so i'm just gonna wait for them to
remote view so yeah i'm looking through everything to see
what's wrong and then have them access my bank account and
my bitcoin wallet and then take all and then take all of it
and then send me amazon gift cards too ask me and then use
my PC to buy Amazon gift cards and then send it over to
them.
You know, the usual, you know, when you give, you know, the
usual when your friend helps you out with your remote
access.
Doesn't your friend do that too?
For some reason, he keeps asking me to buy him Amazon gift
cards.
I don't know why.
I don't know how that's supposed to help me fix my PC.
But, hey, if it helps, it helps.
Yeah, and he also asked me to download this Minecraft mod.
and everything
yeah I did buy it but do not redeem one time I actually
redeemed it and he got really mad at me I started yelling at
me shout at me why did you redeem your Amazon gift card I
don't know I don't know what I'm doing I just want to I just
want to work I just want my PC back to stream me oh yeah I
almost forgot to mention He had to, he had to, he installed
something in my PC.
I don't know what it means, but apparently it's mining
something.
I hope it's like mining diamonds in my, I think it's mining
diamonds or something in Minecraft.
He didn't give me much instructions, but, um, but, um, he
said it was something to do with mining and everything.
And how it helps, it helps, uh, speed up the PC and the bit
rate.
yeah yeah mining diamonds oh my they gave me a shovel spoon
and then it broke it fucking broke off okay this is a sad
tiramisu this is such a it's okay i fixed it i just have to
put it back i'm eating my sad tiramisu and tell you how it
tastes it's not as bad as it looks i will say that it so
looks very sad for those putting it back on the screen it
still looks very sad but at least it's not as it doesn't
taste as sad as it looks
I would say great I've had a lot of tiramisu it's not great
it's like it's okay it's tiramisu you know
it's not the best tiramisu i've ever had it's it's tiramisu
and to be fair you can't really fuck up tiramisu in general
all right i'm just gonna eat half of it
i'll just eat half of it i'm all right
Oh, so, oh, man, I really wanted to finish this game today,
too.
I think it's going to crash again.
I have a feeling.
But, we'll get as far as we can before the next crash.
Tomorrow, I might do a stress test on the PC after some
fixes and stuff with my friend, or my tech friend, and we'll
see how it goes.
We'll do some, you know, I'll close this browser and see if
I need.
All right All right, here we go back at it again Sorry about
all the crashes though.
I know it like I you know, I do always want to give you guys
a good stream experience Oh my god to fight this guy again
So I'm sorry guys Of the crashes You hope you're still
having a fun time watching even with the technical
difficulties Oh in and out where is he?
Already?
Oh my god, I swear to you.
I have to fight this guy again.
Now I'm going to finish it.
I'm just going to...
Oh my god.
I'm going to readjust after eating.
I can't aim right now because I just ate.
No, I want you to eat.
Your aim just gets a little sluggish.
I don't remember how to shoot my gun again.
What the fuck?
Who shot me?
Alright, there you go.
try to speed run this as much as you can I still can't
believe at the reset all the way back just because like
actual bullshit just like
all right nice double barrel shotgun all right back at it
but this gunfighter I got my I got my acid again oh the sad
tiramisu debuff yeah exactly all
right nice I got the shot yeah forget about it oh wait
there's a safe here wait time out gotta crack a safe all
right here's There you go.
Nice.
Time out, this is important!
Alright, I got the little guys.
Alright, he can't do anything about it.
There you go.
That's fucking right.
I know you can't do anything about it.
I've played these games before.
Maybe like three or four times later.
Where is he?
All right, that's fine.
It didn't hit me.
There we go.
He missed.
Oh, he didn't miss.
What?
Where did he go?
Okay, what the fuck?
What?
Okay, I got a...
All right, nice.
Oh, nice.
Oh, you guys can't see my HP, but it was at a very nice
number
Yeah, that's a camera Nice, okay, there we go We could keep
shooting for an hour and neither of us would win.
I just handed you your ass.
I'm skipping this.
I can't wash this again Oh wait, I can use my cheese
Okay, we can wait Oh my, I didn't realize.
I didn't realize it's cheese allowed.
That's right.
If you can blow fire, I could drink the health potions here.
There we go.
Oh my god, not the stupid fire.
Oh, wait, he burned the death.
Yay!
Okay, there's friendly fire.
At least we know there's friendly fire.
Thank God.
He just stayed there, I guess.
He heard about my PC issues, too.
He felt for me.
He felt bad for me.
Thank God.
Yay for pity.
I'm glad I got pity on it.
Sliped right out, that minks.
And now she's littering too.
Oh my God.
Crime worse than murder.
Oh, how the turns have tabled.
I slipped through your fingers.
don't pal it's only wrinkles that magnificent bro i used to
dream of roughly yours bib ps bmp killed betty oh that's
good to know letter for me oh that woman god damn litterer
sure she got away but it didn't feel like a bust the mystery
was solved that scott account for something right there he
goes again it's a shame we there he goes He was such a good
dog for a while.
Like, like he was not barking at anything.
Streams were nice and nice and bark free for a while.
I don't know what got him to lately.
Well, Vivian's out of the picture.
Pretty sure Wanda could spend a killer piece out of this.
Good old dog.
Like, she got away.
the copy of the mouse bird and by the current edit sheet
back when he was just a hack with more ambition than sense
it's packed with accusations aimed straight at the big mouse
party shady details with the tinsel bros handshakes with old
world interest groups even whispers of bribery and murder I
don't mind the bark the only I mind it only because I don't
want my neighbors to come like complain again like he was
being such a good dog I just didn't want to have noise
complaints also why I closed my door is because like I don't
want noise complaints and I did like soundproof my room a
little bit too um but I moved my I realized he hasn't been
barking a lot so I moved some of the extra soundproof stuff
out because it was very hot in my room uh with all the
soundproofing stuff so I removed some of the soundproofing
only because that's why you guys hear him a lot more to a
lot more easier um just because it was really hot in my room
so I didn't want to I was like oh um oh like he's he's been
he's hasn't been barking and everything but yeah I just
didn't want to have a noise complaint because last time the
neighbors weren't happy about it uh even his whispers of
bribery and murder the fact that said editor chief after
briefs stayed in the ER swiftly became a card carrying BMP
loyalist it's definitely a pure coincidence I hope he
doesn't smell anything I don't want to be paranoid or
anything.
It's like those cats that could smell cancer.
Alright.
Hey.
Psst.
Boss.
Bossy boss.
I think the thing he's smelling is food.
No, no.
Because he only barks.
He only barks when I'm on the PC.
The docks.
Or ghosts.
I've got some business to drop Anchor on.
Why do you ask?
See, I've got this friend.
Because it's only when I'm on the PC that he's barking.
I found out a fake cheese more times than I can count.
A street-wise, mob-oriented, conspiracy-savvy.
The kind of guy who can smell a cheese storm from a mile
away.
And, well, looks like he stuck his nose in the wrong mouse
hole.
No.
I've been dead silent for a week now, and that ain't like
him.
No, sir.
I went to my mob contact for answers.
But all I got was a boot to the teeth.
See, right here.
get to the point bozo uh right white on the street is i
don't even want to say it but they what they say he sleeps
with the fish the aquarium check it out just he works at the
aquarium now i don't uh i knew i could count on you boss oh
the best of bosses he smells the cancer on my pc he smells
the antivirus that's crazy though did you guys hear about
the new virus the hatha virus it was called the antivirus
but like how um how the moment the ship's docked everybody
just went home even though they were like technically like
when they like quarantined on the ship for a while too um
and and then they're like oh it seems like every you guys
I'll just go home.
Like, go back home.
So when he asked me to buy him just a small wheel of blue
cheese, I hit the nearest drugstore.
By the time I got back, well, he was done for it.
But I had an idea.
He named it the Hanta virus, but everyone calls it the Hanta
virus.
Well, not, you know what I mean when I say everyone.
The internet causes that.
Ha ha ha.
I love cruises You know like I was gonna go on a cruise
Recently I was invited to do a cruise with some friends And
then I debated for a while But I was like I've been
traveling way too much Because I have to travel again For
behind the scenes stuff Next month So I was just like I
can't do like a vacation I can't do a vacation or anything
Because I already Japan too so I was just like I I can't do
it I want to I want to stream because I haven't been
streaming a lot um this I feel like I personally have been
streaming a lot this year because I've been traveling a lot
too uh yeah the northern yeah I I canceled it because
northern lion canceled the cruise so now I don't have to go
anywhere no it was just it was just a cruise I've never been
on a cruise before um so it's been my first experience on
the cruise um but then I was like no I canceled it I was
like I'm not gonna go because I was just like I I want to um
i miss streaming and i miss hanging out with you guys and
i've been i've been taking a lot of day off i've been i've
been traveling a lot too not just day off but also traveling
a lot for work and everything so i want like i feel like i
already had my vacation in japan so i was like i'm just
gonna i just gonna like go back to work and stuff so i
didn't take it and i was like oh thank god i was like oh my
god at least i i know i was not on the ship to get the virus
but that was just like oh my god cruises are scary you get
there's a whole fucking viral new strain of virus now around
um with a 40% mortality rate
yeah uh seems hastily redacted barely making sense it
recounts the tale of an unnamed mouse who allegedly declared
that fit for mage spiked these newest health product would
make him immortal he dug down a dose of strachine to test
the syria word has it that the coroner's face bomb still be
heard echoing through the alleys of mouthworks to this day
yeah that was crazy I was just like oh my god thank god I
didn't take the cruise it wasn't the hanta virus cruise by
the way it's just cruise in general I was just like oh I
didn't want to risk it yeah and here I was hoping to squeeze
some juicy headlines out of you what happened bad case of a
case going bad it didn't just go bad it wrapped me around
its finger like a piece of string sent me chasing my own
tail through a parade of crooks and ghosts and somewhere
along the way an innocent if deeply corrupt mouse took a
bullet charming um what do you call this case i wonder yeah
you're already planning to make a hell of a piece out of
this cheese storm ain't you the woman's name jack because
there was a woman right there's always a woman miss vivian
mccarthy it was gonna be like a three to four day cruise so
it wasn't gonna be a Oh, you don't mean that hot-headed
starlet who torpedoed her own career by spiking the
director's fondue with blue cheese to make it more amicable.
Well, I didn't know that.
Yeah, well, it wasn't exactly front-page news.
Tinsel Avenue's big wigs swept it under the rug.
Bad looking all.
Not really.
She's quite easy on the eyes.
Oh, right.
So what's her angle?
Vivian was chasing ghosts.
Swore her friend Betty Lynch didn't just OD and said it was
a setup.
Blamed the film industry for it.
Turns out she was half right.
It was a hit.
Just had nothing to do with tensils.
Betty was the type to show up at every party sticking her
nose where it didn't belong.
Thought she could play all sides and not get burned.
I checked, and...
Well, let's just say it involved BMP notables.
So I looked into Miles Kerr, BMP's mouthpiece, checking if
he was the guy who tied the noose.
But nah.
Kerr was tangled up with Betty, sure, but he wasn't the
executioner.
Vivian, on the other hand, didn't wait for the jury.
She jumped a gun in the most literal sense.
Later I found out the mob was behind it.
One party too many, you know?
Betty ran her mouth to the wrong ear.
I probably didn't even mean to.
By the time I figured out the mob had Betty whacked, Kurd
was already a pile of dust and a very expensive suit.
And?
And seam.
You did at least try to catch her, right?
to talk some sense into her you can guess how well that went
he's a slippery little thing the most dangerously curved
tail i've ever seen oh whoa she's long gone by now probably
skip town oh jack lipstick smudge letter a guilty conscience
very active of her you know what i'll fill in the details
myself this is sixth page true detective fluff anyway Is
that your tail, Jack?
Are you happy to see her?
You're not making it easy, Jack.
Like, not at all.
Damn.
Minute report, too.
My sir.
That cur- How curve?
Oh, man.
The tails go on for miles.
Jack, good seeing you.
Some friendly advice, John.
I'm not your grocery service.
So if you're sent to me on another mission to fetch whatever
nightmare fuel you call food think again no no no jack
nothing weird this time see i i hear seafoods the hot stuff
on the streets lately and i just so happen oh everyone it's
from the aquarium right or go to the submarine and the
aquarium area fresh turd bow or a handful of crap cakes huh
it's just a can of sea slugs jack relax oh oh so can i count
on you no you count on break but i will keep an eye out
what's crawled up his coat this time i think i think i
honestly i think i know why he's why dad's been like barking
too i think he wants to he wants to use my bed because every
time i every time i uh every morning i kick him out of my
room because he's only allowed to sleep in my bed super when
he's supervised because i don't want his house Because I've
noticed, like, because I had a little scare where he, like,
jumped off the bed again.
Because I let the door open.
And then, like, I heard him jump down again.
And I was like, no!
Nope!
Go down on the bed now when I'm there.
I don't know why he does that.
Like, the stairs are literally right next to him.
It's, like, it's next to them, and he still decides to jump.
It's, like, it's faster.
I was like, it is not faster.
It is not faster.
I'm jumping so much,
It's like, literally...
Okay, I'll show you as an illustration.
It pisses me off every time.
That's why he's not allowed.
He's not allowed in the bed whenever, like, I'm not there.
Alright.
Here's the bed.
Here's...
You don't see it yet, but don't worry.
Just doing little barks, and I hear him.
Here's the...
Okay, I'm trying to draw in 3D.
And then...
These are the stairs.
And then he would jump.
He would go here.
And then he would jump this way.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, so...
I'll show you guys.
Oh my, there he goes again.
There he goes.
Yes, I'm talking about you.
Yes, I'm talking about you right now.
Yes, I know.
That's right.
What you going to do about it?
He knows.
He knows we're talking about him.
He knows we're talking shit.
That's right.
I will shave him.
All right, this is what he does.
Oh, my gosh.
Actually, he's getting a little louder.
It is.
You bastard.
It's tough.
I can't do it.
Anyway, you stop.
Alright, so...
So this is what I mean.
He fucking...
Bed is here.
Sears is literally right here.
It's literally right here.
And then he would jump there.
And I was like, Why?
Why?
So he can't do that.
I can't let him in my room unsupervised.
What a thrill.
He needs the thrill.
So, like, it's the adrenaline rush.
You don't get it, Doki.
You won't understand.
So it's like every time I went, it's like a 50-50.
So I don't trust him.
I don't trust him unless...
Because when I'm there, I'd be like...
I'd like stop him when he like thinks about it.
I'd be like, no!
And then I'd be like, nudge him with my feet.
I was just like, no, and I'd push him towards the stairs.
So I don't trust him when I'm on the PC and I'm streaming.
I can't trust that dog.
it back to the submarine you wouldn't get it toky you
wouldn't understand it was time to catch some i've been
thinking about i've been thinking about like or making it so
that my bed is just all upstairs so then he's he has nowhere
to jump i thought i did think about it it was in my head
what the what the was the point of that train why
is it like that oh okay I just got a little too excited I
unlocked the shortcut already oh yeah you see that chainsaw
there you go there's more than just a chainsaw got to go
this way What the fuck?
I already unlocked the short, but...
I want to fight.
Alright.
I know I already have sped run, but I want to fight!
That's right.
I'll be part of the action still.
Oh yeah, there it is.
supposed to go.
Where's this leading me?
Oh, back up here.
Okay.
So I had to go there.
Oh, whoops.
I forgot to use my tail.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
We need the armor here.
Okay, nice.
we're back here wait but then what's over here what was over
here wait what was down there though oh nothing it was
nothing it was just a little bed shortcut
there we go oh shit
reload all right nice
Oh my god, that's a lot of shots That's a lot of gunshots
Alright, it's okay I had armor on me A shot on all sides
there But it's okay, I live Just a scratch Oh, there's a
submarine But I might need a civilized way to tell them
There is the There is the Hot pepper.
We're gonna need that.
All fire now.
Oh, there's the sniper.
I see you.
No snapping for you.
All right.
Everyone's burning to death.
Yippee!
Oh.
Oh!
Not getting out of this.
Sniper, no sniping.
Okay, so that's what I have to get.
Is it?
Oh, no?
Oh, wait, this is a clue!
Oh, it's the sea slugs!
The scent of fresh fish get a side of the waterstuffs.
Alright.
I got the sea slugs.
The little bonus side quest.
I better be paid a lot for this.
It's been bougie shit right there.
Alright, what is that?
What did I do?
I just moved the platform.
Oh, wait, there's another switch.
What did I say?
I just moved the platform, but it doesn't look like I did
anything with it.
All right, open the door.
Wait, what did I do with this?
Doesn't look like it changed anything.
Alright.
Oh, is that parkour?
Wait, that's a parkour area.
Does it though?
Come on, look at me.
Look at me, I got ice cream.
Look at me.
Look at me, I got your favorite fondue.
Look at me, keep looking.
Aww, made you look.
Why did he look?
Okay, but where am I supposed to...
Oh, there is...
Oh my god, it's a secret.
Hey, nice.
It's too slow.
I couldn't get him his ice cream.
He didn't...
If he kept looking, he could have got it.
He promised him...
No, my thought he died.
If he stayed alive for one more second, you could have got
ice cream.
That's on him.
Nice armor.
Where am I supposed to go?
Alright, this way.
Which means I can go this way for loot.
No entry.
For loot.
What do you mean no entry?
Is that a secret?
It's not a secret, but it's avid.
though and then 20 dogs all right we go this way huh I would
have thought there was something over here but I guess not
oh Tami what is Tami doing here Tami is dangerous oh That's
a shortcut.
Hey kiddo, what are you doing here?
Yeah, what is she doing here?
Well, what are you sniffing around the docks for?
I was chasing one crazy egghead than anyone underwater.
Ah, ever on the quest for justice.
Need some help?
Frankly, I do.
I need to go below.
I saw one of those water D diving suits.
Whoa, my almost pa.
No, no, no, no, no.
those corporate shills what you need is a custom tailored
fancy schmancy diving suit with a cherry on top and i can
make you one are you okay certified didn't you mean
certified to do that tell me let me see uh a helmet heavy
spiked boots and the suit itself oh like the big ones the
big ones where you're like walk down the water scooby-doo
ones for the other to please don't tell me how to keep
whacking everyone till somebody drops it what that's just
plain dumb who would do something like that okay here's the
deal i know a guy who knows a guy who knows a shrew working
here in the docks names eddie he's a filthy effing fondue
head plastered from dawn until yeah the scuba do diving
suits but well you know heart of gold
Yeah, I like how the boats are all seen but worse, uh, you
know the way you came in he must have a pair of boots If he
didn't pawn them off already you probably missed him on the
way here.
He went for a piss or another glass of cheese Yeah, and the
helmet and we're not getting that I do not know but if you
find Eddie you must just ask him that bastard sniffed around
every hole in this area So he could help you or just say
that Tammy effing tumbler is calling in that favor what
favor jack jack jack jack you like a father to me but come
on there's a limit okay take yes been summoned he has been
summoned i don't know i don't know what's triggering him oh
now oh now i can go there okay it was locked before but now
it's open Miss, I talked to Tammy.
Alright.
I should kill him.
I swear to God, if you want to bark at me, come closer.
He's not coming closer.
That's all I'm going to say.
Am I going to...
Okay, there you go.
Fuck this.
Oh, and I still don't kill him.
The fact that he barks from the...
Oh, my God, from his bed, too.
He's like, don't you come over.
here no no you come over here oh my god oh my god
every time every every time I come over and then he goes he
instantly gets out his bed and goes into this little dog
house.
I was like, what do you want?
He's like,
every time he fucking goes into this little dog house too.
He's like, oh, I made you look.
He come and get me.
He, I made you look.
What did I not go up here?
My side great I just killed everyone already oh there they
are I was gonna say
like pet like oh no hey but there's something over here I'm
going for it he made me look guys did it again mom mom mom
mom mom hi He fucking did it again.
He made me love.
Get rage baited, nerd.
That's the who's a boss every now and then.
Thank you, Lucifer.
Chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, down here?
Zoom here.
Alright.
Oh, is that it?
Oh, that was it.
Oh, unless...
Nice, I got Thomas, Thomas.
What?
Oh, oh, there it is.
Okay, I'm locked the shortcut.
Wait, what's on this ship?
Oh, nothing.
Okay, nothing's on here.
Except for some ammo.
It was just me.
money it's okay i'm five thousand dollars at this point i'm
only i'm doing the safe at this point for like for the
thrill of it for the challenge it's just it's for the
challenge at this point
you're missing money you could have gotten get out of here
now fast as you can my wife my your ex-wife pal they'll be
fine but you you disappear leave the city don't look back
you look proper stuffed up can you uh do me a solid do a wet
now you know a favor see my wifey so good and kind and I'm
such a low life oh that's so sad where do I come in anytime
she's a good host we'll give you cookies and stuff fine what
do you want from me see I got a diving gig right and she
thinks I'm actually working for that damn cold fondue always
gets in the way oh he needs an intervention i got a helmet
in my home that's convenient almost as if by design now go
down there doesn't that's it doesn't have to smack enough
slip in get the helmet get out my dear dear marie
don't that's not fair all right it's all right buddy it's
gonna be our wife soon i need that helmet either way so what
all right we gotta go get the helmet he told me to did you
say look he says like please talk to my wife i was like all
right if you insist He insisted.
Not hear him?
He asked me to talk to his wife.
Oh.
Ian, it can still work.
I can make it work.
Oh.
Alright.
I guess I go.
Yeah, he said I could come in at any time.
I mean, she looks...
She looks interested!
I'm gonna say!
Got all of it?
Yeah, just don't get me started on Eddie.
Yeah, yeah, no, I won't.
I know I'm all too well.
Now, give me them goods.
This goes in here.
Plug in.
I don't know if I could trust a first-time diving suit.
So...
Made by a gun inventor.
Guns, diving suit?
Practically the same thing.
The anti-shock cages right here on the boat.
One is death by bullets.
The other is death by water pressure.
Oh, did I miss the secret?
Don't worry.
What kind of secret, though?
The secret with his wife?
Both has pressure seals so straight.
What's the secret?
Just going to...
Oh,
is that her before?
Before he ruined her life?
Up the ladder.
There's a secret up the ladder?
What ladder?
This ladder?
That's where I was.
Ladders?
There was no secret in that room.
Just wanted to see her again.
Just wanted to look at her.
all right let's see how to go all right it's time to go yes
and go left oh my god all right what ladder this ladder
there's no left here there's no ladders around here i don't
see no ladders there's health
Oh, that's such a sad mattress.
That's so sad.
Oh, that's so sad.
Ladder where?
That's it.
I'm going back.
I'm not turning around this time.
You can get me.
You can go out of bounds.
All right.
Maybe you have got me.
Okay.
Now I'm interested.
Now I'm curious what he means by out of bounds.
All right.
No.
No, you did get me.
You did...
Beyond the ladder.
Never mind.
Oh, the other...
This ladder.
Oh, this ladder.
What?
What the fuck does he mean?
Yeah, that got my attention.
What about?
The fence?
This?
Oh.
What are you mousing around here for, huh?
You shouldn't be here, damn it.
Fucking gamers.
Wait, what language is this?
developer situation yeah another one job out of bounds as me
yeah well i will pick a lot of explaining i just put oh it's
polish devs i was gonna say this polish now but i don't want
to get i was worried of getting it wrong because european
languages it's like a 50 50 when it comes to
Okay, listen up, you rascal.
I'm going to open up a warp pipe.
Oh, yeah, thank you.
And you promise, promise, to cut all that bullshit.
We good.
Ta-ta.
Oh, yeah, I get a little Funko Pop, too.
Sorry, YouTube's.
But is this a Funko Pop or YouTube's?
I heard it's like...
Um...
I remember if it's YouTube, twos are a Funko Pop.
Because I know, like, the collectibles are based off one of
them.
Oh, that's cool.
It's a little...
Tata.
A little developer, fourth wall.
Alright, now off we go.
Off we go to the ocean.
Polish or medicine before.
Is it Polish or is it medicine?
I was like, is it Pokemon or is it a chemistry chemical?
Oh, it's this song.
Oh, where have I heard this song?
It's like a classic song.
I've heard this from Little Mermaid, right?
It reminds me of the Kingdom Hearts Little Mermaid level.
Yeah, it's a classic.
I feel like I've heard this and actually in the in the
little mermaid kingdom hearts area
because I've been stuck there for I was stuck there for a
long time when I was a kid because I get kept getting
confused I didn't know where I kept getting lost when I had
to swim what does he eat me oh oh poison bad
Wait, but I want to get...
But the thing!
Oh, he poisons places when he's on.
Oh!
I see.
Oh, I hate this level already.
I'm sorry, I already hate this area.
This area fucking sucks already.
Yeah, I don't like...
I think it's worse because it is in black and white, so it's
so hard to see.
And the helmet, too.
I think it's the helmet part.
Okay, I gotta get that pearl.
Okay.
The armor.
What's over here?
Is this a secret?
Oh, it is.
What is he doing here?
Sleeps with the fishes.
Oh, he is!
See, I told you!
He's in the aquarium!
makes me calm yeah i did not i did not like the reflection
oh
found a secret within the secret oh my god i wish i was not
looking at my fucking face right now i'm trying to explore
i've been here
oh my god where where am i where where where okay okay i've
been here before
Yeah, it being stuck on selfie mode is not it.
Really?
It just got there!
Of course, of course that still hits me.
I'm still poison!
Wait, no, he doesn't see me.
There's no poison here, I think?
No.
it's just not a lot of contrast in this level that makes it
like a lot harder to see and also the fucking permanent
selfie mode that too
yeah it's his reflection it's very annoying because it's
like I could I'm already struggling right now brother I'm
already yeah it's just all gray there's not a lot of
contrast for this area Which I'm not a fan with.
If there was more contrast it would look a lot better.
It's definitely a choice.
Can't wait when they- yeah, I can't wait when they release
this in Technicolor, guys.
Maybe then I'll finally realize.
I finally know what the color yellow is.
Am I supposed to shoot?
Wait, what am I supposed to shoot?
Look, I'm- I'm trying to figure out where to shoot.
Can I break this?
No, I can't.
What do I shoot at?
Okay, I can't kick that.
Uh...
Give
me a sec.
I'm trying to figure out what the cues are.
Wait.
Nope.
That doesn't do anything.
I'm gonna follow the cables.
Do I shoot this?
No.
Oh, shit.
Alright, never mind.
I have one HP left.
Oh, I can break it.
Oh!
Some things in here don't react well to bullets.
Okay, I can break it.
It just took a while.
It just...
Okay, that's good to know.
I was like, can I break this?
Oh, whoops, I stood next to the explosion.
Guys, do not stand near next to explosion, guys.
Explosion's bad.
Pro tip.
There must be another...
Oh, no, okay.
Yeah, no, I kept standing next to explosion.
I kept standing next to it.
I was like, don't worry.
I'm invincible.
Like, wrong game.
Fire pet.
Note that down, guys.
Note that down.
Fire and explosion bad.
Oh my god, I'm still next to it again.
I'm still next to it again.
Will I ever learn?
Final next time.
On Doki Ball Z.
Alright.
Just send this in.
Whoops.
Yeah, where is he?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, my gosh, she's next to her.
Oh, no.
That's bad.
Sorry, there is a health here.
I remember there was health here.
Whoops.
Oh, I need more health.
Oh, nice.
Got more here.
Listen, professor.
Here I come.
You deserve help.
Is there another one?
Oh, shit!
There was another one.
Oh, what?
Okay, how does that?
How does it hit me?
Oh, my God.
I was going to Zari attract this.
Guys, do you think I should...
Is he telling me to stop breaking his submarine?
I can't tell.
What is he trying to say?
Jesus Christ, this is gonna take... fuck this.
Here we go.
No, he said... is he saying stop breaking my submarine?
Or is he saying something else?
Is he saying that chocolate chips are great?
Like, I can't tell.
Stop breaking my submarine!
I can't tell.
I can't tell from his accent what he's trying to say.
Stop taking my subway sandwich?
Is that it?
This axe is a little too thick.
I can't steal that.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm good.
There he is.
What?
How?
He didn't walk.
He was through the door.
Oh, my God.
Those robots were fucking walling.
They were walling.
They had...
storming in without knocking yeah he did it he made her he
made you stop and you should have stopped breaking his
submarine bro he no clip he had the no clip hack
some things in it
all right well
i'm gonna use my mind juice on it
Stop eating my food at the, in the lunch fridge?
Oh, guess I'll never know.
I'll never know what he's trying to say.
Oh, wrong button.
I don't know.
What is he trying to tell us, guys?
Stop playing vampire crawlers.
Is that it?
Quilla, we've ever know.
Stop investing in Bitcoin?
Stop investing in...
In the EA stock market?
Stop...
Nah, that can't be it.
Oh, well, we're ahead of him there, then.
Who is that?
Let's see it.
Stop updating my PC drivers?
Well, that's too late.
No, I could go.
Stop petting my cat?
Stop letting dad get away with things?
That might be it.
Stop eating grilled cheese with dad food.
Stop what?
I guess I'll never know.
What do I stop with?
Stop rage beating us?
Wait, what?
What?
Why is that one?
Take care of the others.
There you are.
Oh, there he is.
You can't fathom.
Stop fighting?
for you stop giving him tangerines yeah
yeah yeah killing first dinner later
oh great he's not just mad he's a full-blown idiot okay
that's fine i'm safe right here right all
right I don't know
if I can use it'll break via acid.
Okay, yeah, it does.
Oh, is it broken already?
I can't tell.
Nice.
Whoops.
I think it's broken.
It's so hard to tell.
Oh.
There we go.
Now I don't want down.
I should not break these.
Oh, I can't.
Wait, no, I can't.
Alright, nice.
I got the head.
And we need to reload.
All I can make is that.
It's definitely stop break.
It's definitely not stop break.
Yeah, that's the only thing I know.
But I can't make out what he wants me to do.
I know for sure it's nothing to do with the submarine.
I Just I just don't know what it could be A real cop for a
minute left
Oh my god, he said something else now he said another line
The fuck Basha there
I got everything
Oh wait, there's a timer
What else is there left?
Oh, my God.
I didn't even see that.
I'm not yet, darling.
You're not slithering away this time.
Oh, my God.
I was supposed to kill him.
I'm still alive.
Oh, my God.
Not even close.
Never punished.
That's in time.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Why does he want it?
Why do you want it?
Oh my god.
He's got that.
Stop breaking the summary.
Never punished.
What am I supposed to do now?
Wait, maybe I did get punished.
Wait a minute.
Oh,
that's awkward.
I may or may not have gotten punished.
They might...
Oh.
Unless...
Wait, maybe he left some...
Oh, there it is.
There he is.
Looks like Yuri just got defunded.
Dude turns out the scientists were brought to mouse for
three years ago by none other than the representatives of
the big mouse Okay, there we go looks like I Never get
punished.
There we go Look at that
Had me worried there for a second.
Yeah, I was like whoa shit.
Okay, I want to get wet again Am I not wearing the fucking
dives?
Okay, there you go.
God No, not back here again.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, shit.
Wait, they got the fish.
Oh, wait.
The fish was never real.
That's my car.
Look at that.
Never punished, guys.
Never punished.
I guess we'll never know what he was saying, guys.
What he wanted me to stop doing.
It'll forever be a mystery.
Either I stopped something big or kick-started it.
Wanda's in for a recap.
Corny, too.
We will never know.
One of life's greatest mysteries.
On the other, this one has a very uplifting front page.
A mouse soldier kissing a shrewd mouse.
Nurse.
That there's no way that's the shrew look how tall she is
the affair is over that's fake that's photoshop quite big
affairs finally over and all brave surviving soldiers can at
least return home that's not a map that's not true no way
she's a shrew it's like that youtube channel you know like
the youtube channel where like uh we're like uh uh a dwarf a
dwarf mom he birthed to like a regular-sized kid.
Like, can Shrews do that?
The Shrew just gives birth to a mouse-sized Shrew?
I don't want to use any of these, because I don't use any of
these guns, really.
I guess I'll do the cannon.
Yeah, there's a YouTube channel whose shorts show up on my
feed sometimes, where it's basically the guy's life living
as a regular-sized kid who entire family are like dwarves or
like short people yeah Jack Wanda you're looking downright
chipper case closed on Bandal I take it well let's just say
I put a major dent in the offshore import of fringe science
milaki like I really infringed on future peer reviews of
those I kids i mean i it was infringemental yes yes jack
because it's like genetics like the what is it called
although i gotta admit he could take a bullet what is like
the medical condition yeah well is it just short people
cause in trouble no more i remember can sleep easy tonight
and i couldn't have done it without you wonder all right
caught one of the professors it's all pro bono dwarfism yeah
to make for a hell of a headline speaking of which hold off
on running the story just yet huh that's a first you usually
love getting your stories out there the mysterious pi has
done it again and such something about keeping the clients
coming if there will always be that case i'll never be able
to crack the case of stop whatever he was too many hands i
guess these scientists love to play the make case of stop
something i'll never know what he'll want me to stop This
horror show was running on serious money, and I don't know
where it's coming from.
You think it's local?
Someone with enough pull to bankroll the operation and keep
it off the books?
Well, I doubt the crooked cops came up with feeding the
shrews to lab rats on their own.
Someone was making them promises, and then wouldn't you know
it, poof.
See, I told you.
I told you the chief was not the main guy.
Oh, look, I know they're no saints, but this feels a little
too spy-thrillery for my team.
taste you got anything conclusive to work with no not yet
it's like i'm right in the center of a tangled knot of
string cheese the case of the stop breaking redacted
redacted but all i've got so far is a gut feeling your gut
feelings have a nasty habit of turning out right it's the
collateral what if it's cornelius at the end either bmp's
clean or i'm missing a piece just give me a few days I feel
like it would be a villain we've never seen before.
As it may sound, I believe in you.
Almost as much as I believe in the power of the press.
What if it was me all alone?
I don't know.
I feel like there's no way the big villain would be someone
we haven't seen before.
I don't know.
Or maybe it will be.
Who knows?
I personally hope it's someone that we've seen in the game
so far.
What if it's Millie?
It's her all along.
She killed her dad.
Yeah.
Or is it the guy in the prologue?
Oh, I have to be such a cop-out if it's the guy from the
prologue.
Here you go, you're canned gastrologue.
It was Millie all along.
It's this orphan situation where she's actually a
50-year-old woman with dwarfism.
If it's all the same to you, I'll just be.
Oh, no, no, no.
You're not leaving without a taste.
John, you build like that bar stalled under your feet.
You can't stop me.
time shrew thicket bare-knuckle bare-ass wrestling champion
can do I can have you in a headlock before you blink come on
humor me just one bite the things I do that's the spirit now
chew chew here comes the food chain well son of a gun that's
actually good right right huh and just wait till they sit in
the cellar for a Real flavor magic.
This is why I stockpile melted cheese.
Thank you.
There was one guy like Jorfism.
And then after 21, he got gigantism.
It was 4.8 at 21, but died at 7.2.
Oh, that's crazy.
Genetics go crazy, bro.
That's actually...
Wow, that's interesting that that happened.
Like, I basically hit, like, late-stage puberty, and it
never stopped.
but yeah basically dwarfism is a dominant gene so like um
it's very the fact that they have like a normal sized kid is
like very very like if two two people with dwarfism had a
kid most like like most likely they'll have a child will
also have dwarfism because the genes are dominant so like
the guy the guy like has like youtube shorts about what his
life is like living with family where he's like the only
regular size only like regular size kid growing up yes he is
what what i'm confused boss how's that good news i don't
know he looked cozy there had a nice rock for a pillow and
everything that's not cozy that's that no he was sort of
breathing underwater i don't know how i was in a uh diving
suit serious you ain't pulling my leg you're standing on
them so no Yeah, I'm just gonna go check myself.
Thanks for nothing, boss.
What do you mean?
Everybody's a detective these days.
I literally told the truth.
I would never lie.
Or another clue.
It's getting a little full.
The picture's starting to form.
And every clue to your evidence.
BMP radicals all the way through.
It was all connected.
mocking every wasted hour but now now I had them the case
had to rest and so did I my god cuz tomorrow it would all
come crashing down and I would be there I got all the clues
it's all coming together guys every one of them it all leads
the BMP I knew it was all connected You see the lines,
Charlie?
Yes, yeah.
It's like that sunny in Philadelphia.
I mean, it's all connected.
Guys.
It all goes to the top.
And they're all in on it, too.
Anything you need, boss?
Actually, yes.
You got that slippery look like a guy who knows things he
ain't supposed to.
Oh.
You flatter me, boss.
The bestest of...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look, I need intel on that towering Hulk from Wallop Bay.
Towering who now?
There were three of them.
A weirdo scientist, a crooked cop, and a...
Third guy.
Humongous one.
Oh, pierogi.
Oh, no, thanks.
Not hungry.
No, no, no.
My best, boss.
Pierogi, Jake.
The Hulk kind of name is that.
because he's a big boy his real name is bunz jacob bunz but
everybody calls him pierogi jake all right so who the hell
is he spill it already right right uh small time crook used
to run with the boys a bit of boyglary some skull cracking
the usual dark side stuff then he got noticed started
climbing out of the gutter went big time got on bmp's
payroll right and now he's there right And man, let me get
this straight small time quick wakes up one day and
suddenly.
Oh, is that guy I forgot about that guy He like literally
showed up for like one second on the newspaper Well, uh,
boss the world's a funny place ain't it there's gotta be a
plot twist.
I hope there's a plot twist It was Betty Betty shows up.
Well, she faked her death good Intel ain't free.
I have to provide you know crazy for no reason she was
always alive oh yeah no i bet you that that guy's gonna be
used as a fall guy cornelius we need to talk uh shoot your
shot sport just make it quick got a mayoral debate uh razzle
dazzle and a few i found steve oh that's great news
fantastic even i see i just knew he the bucket we weren't
called the invincible he's got three robot girlfriends for
nothing i don't want to say nothing now he has four
girlfriend by the way look corny oh fine story to the
stretch got himself into the shrew abductions curds
premature rapture and the mob tightening its grip i don't
know something ain't sitting right with me oh it just feels
like there's a common denominator like somebody pulling the
cheese strings.
And who might that be, Jack?
That's what's bothering me.
I don't know.
My running theory is it's someone tied to BMP, or at least
playing nice with them.
But I'm still missing too many pieces.
Figured maybe you caught a whip or something during your
campaign.
Anything at all, throw me a crumb here.
Jack, I'd love to.
But I only know what's public.
I call me crazy, but slinging.
I'm a martyr.
The opposition is not exactly your vote winner.
The right charm, though.
You'd be surprised what you can get away with.
I get it, Cornelius.
This ain't in official capacity, of course.
I'm just asking as a friend who just so happens to have
incognito informants, Capiche?
Oh, I'm sorry, Susport.
I know they played dirty.
worse than a weak old rockford but see they're so drunk on
their own fondue they rarely bother to make sure it doesn't
spill if they've got their paws in this mess I trust you to
dig up the proof in the meantime I'm gonna keep fighting on
and even at playing field I can't tell if that makes you an
idealist or a sucker Maybe both.
Wonder what they're gonna tell me.
Good luck, buddy.
You fight your fight, then I'll fight mine.
Alright, let's see who's gonna win.
Alright, off I go.
Wait, what?
What?
What am I missing?
Oh, get some rest.
I just needed to sleep.
I got to sleep.
I was so ready for the grind.
I can't believe this was all happened in one day.
After a day like that, night had to come in soon.
The entire case happened in one day.
That's crazy, guys.
We got a lot of stuff done.
Feverish.
What a day.
Mostly, just some of it burned too hot and way too vivid.
We've been out there for three hours.
A cheese party aftermath or I woke up just when the smoke
got real.
And sure enough, that was fire.
The real kind.
The kind that consumes everything.
Wait, someone tried.
Wait, the entire city!
is on fire.
What the hell's going on?
Hell's going on.
That's what.
Come on.
We got a scram.
Whole damn blocks going up.
Someone's trying to.
Yeah, someone's set the entire city on fire.
Monsters, coppers, party thugs, the whole damn...
All of them?
Damn.
They're after the evidence.
The entire district.
What's his name?
The brown noser?
Sawyer?
Yeah, I stashed it in your bar.
You're stashed?
Get dead?
What?
No wonder these morons are tearing up my joint.
No time to argue.
We gotta find it before they do.
Now get on my back and let's go.
What?
You mean what?
You're not pocket-sized, pal, so get on.
Oh, I swear.
This gets out.
Why is he... He has legs?
Okay, this guy has legs.
We gotta find all the evidence.
He does not have to...
Oh, I'm finally in the basement.
Is this not...
Hard.
Are the dogs not mine?
Are the dogs not the district?
The city's dogs?
Oh my god, I'm gonna hit by everything right now.
Wait, where's Tammy?
Yeah, I was gonna say, those are dog houses in my area.
Where's that?
No, that's shit, not armor.
Is they're home now?
Damn, they gentrified quick Smells like burnt cheese All
right
Nice I'll grab another HP Just wanted to be sure, but who's
that what who's that over there?
How did he get beat up?
Oh
Nice.
Gotta get rid of him.
All right, is he gonna show up?
Oh my god, I missed it.
All right, get out of here.
Oh my god, I missed the...
I missed the explosion.
Oh, oh, oh.
There you go.
That's why you ain't sniping me, boy.
I trained for this exact moment.
I'm not missing.
Oh, no.
Yes, I could have.
All right, now you burn to death.
All right, nice.
That should be everybody.
Oh, never mind.
There's more!
Okay, why is that not shooting you?
All right, now that should be all of you.
Oh, am I frozen?
Whoops.
Okay.
whoops no all right I didn't even realize I didn't even
realize I was frozen the cheese the mob got me they got me I
was very locked in guys I was so locked in
I know where I got it.
It's coming back up.
They got her.
Alright, uh...
Boop.
There we go.
Back.
There you go, I'm back, baby.
They're getting me.
They're not getting me alive!
Wait, I actually I don't just want to check that real quick.
I just heard, like, an explosion.
Wait, they're all dead.
What?
What happened?
How did they all die?
Oh, okay, that's cool.
I literally went back to, like, grab stuff, and then they're
all dead.
How convenient.
Oh, what happened?
Yeah, I was going to say it.
Like, what happened to them?
I wanted to grab some stuff.
It's okay, guys.
I'm only keeping the money for my buddy.
Oh.
I'm just holding it safe for him.
His whole earnings.
Yeah, the group heart attack.
You're owing me for all the damages.
Just give me a second to think.
Jack, we ain't got a second.
You're right.
Let's get the hell out of here.
I'll cook up something on the move.
what you always do all right save turn that on oh secret oh
is that is that what the cheese uh yeah yeah my secret stack
well not just mine I mean I forget it we gotta push forward
which means I gotta do the safe real clear.
Nice.
Wait, how would they even get down here?
Wait, how did they get down here?
Doesn't make sense.
This is my secret tunnel.
Yet there's 20 doors in the secret tunnel?
This doesn't make any sense.
It's not so secret.
I have 800 pathways leading to it.
Oh,
nice.
It's not, apparently not so secret tunnel.
That's what I'm saying.
Why build this elaborate trap door if he has 800 more doors
leading to the fucking secret hideout?
Not so secret anymore.
The very well-known passage.
Tell your friends, everybody.
Tell everyone.
The secret is the name of the tunnel.
How?
Oh, okay.
Oh!
I was like, surely that's just water underneath me, right?
I have whoops.
You almost made it.
The finish line.
Fucked it up on the finish line.
Alright.
Open the door.
How?
I thought...
I legitimately thought that was just...
We made it, John.
I thought that was like water or something.
Pretty sure my eardrum's shot.
Hey.
What do you mean?
Oh, it was.
Yeah.
Thank God for these convenient place arrows and paints.
On my secret hideout.
Alright.
How the hell
would you show me?
Made it to another area.
I'll take the plus two.
Oh, it's the hitman again!
Oh, great.
You again.
What can I say?
We got unfinished business.
All right, sky face.
Where is this?
Wait, I'm frozen?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I cannot cheese this leg black.
Oh,
come on.
That's cheating.
You have AoE.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
Easy.
And this is the hardest difficulty, guys.
What's up with his face?
Just a little accident.
You know, just don't want to decide to...
bothered me, annoying me a little bit.
This gun, yeah, the acid gun is really strong.
That's what you get.
It's a warning to anyone.
To anyone that wakes me from my nap, gotcha.
You're right, I just wanted to make it more symmetrical.
That's true.
In fact, if anything, I was helping him.
I was in the trenches.
Never caught the foot.
Finally, his face is symmetrical now.
paper while artillery wailed overhead we made the breach
deep behind enemy lines and lived to tell the tale but life
life's a special kind of turd breaks anyone just finishing
the job you know my office a pile of ash evidence I always
finished the job gone so I sat down and I had a drink then a
few hundred more first time i didn't know what came next
it's going back to this fondue addiction oh steve he said
since you're in deep and i'm the magician let me be your a
for real steve that's son of a bitch the day you're that's
makina a course told me from the freaking beyond he made a
habit of recording his shadier contact and he left a tape in
a perch with a view somewhere in that mansion of his was the
best and frankly the only bet I had all right it all lies on
this magic mansion it's beautiful magic mansion Wow Steve I
thought we were best friends what the fuck.
You never invited me over?
What the fuck, Steve?
I fucking saved your life!
This man could have gotten... This man was in the war, and
I'll save this man's life.
This entire case...
I'm only being paid one whole dollar.
Who do you think you are, Pee-Haw?
I just cool with Steve.
Perch with a view, just like he said.
Alright, it's over there.
Oh, it's definitely gonna be that easy.
Whoops.
Somehow I matched the missile shots.
Alright.
Can't go over here.
Oh, there's the crocs.
God damn it, Steve.
okay of course the big muppet patrol beat me to it who's so
shaken i'll bet they missed the evidence all right so he's
oh oh my god he even has a maze
jesus and it told you told me you couldn't afford a birthday
present
you gave me an i owe you for My birthday, Steve!
Yeah, how much does a fucking magician make?
Look, he is a magician scientist.
It's different.
Wait, is this top?
No, it's not.
They're just swinging over there.
I should become a magician at this point.
Oh?
It's over here.
Oh, there's a lot of secrets in this area.
Oh, am I gonna drown, guys?
No, I'm okay.
Nothing to worry about.
Sorry, man.
Times are so Steve, after buying his 50th yacht.
Steve, I lend you $50, and I still haven't been paid yet,
Steve.
What the fuck, bro?
Oh, that was a lot worse.
Off-brand, adolescent, genetically modified Martian.
No.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
My good old trusty gun.
I don't even know where I am anymore.
Yeah.
Thank God they're not genetically modified.
Actually, I can spare a cheese.
Alright, let's save here.
Yeah, I went through the maze.
So...
Oh!
Alright, anyway.
Whoa.
Reflex!
Ow.
Thank god I always shoot first and ask questions later.
Oh my god, they're all here.
Oh hey, hey!
I like how you said hi before you shot me, that's nice.
You don't get that nowadays with cokes.
So polite.
I did appreciate that.
Yeah, we have to go this way.
So I'm gonna go this way for loot.
Oh my god!
This area is huge!
Oh, I am taking a lot of damage.
I need my cheese real quick.
Oh, I need a lot of cheese!
Oh no, oh no!
Oh!
Yeah, professionals have standards.
Yeah, I give me a greeting before they kill me.
Yeah, Steve seems to be inviting everybody to his mansion,
except for me.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Can't really start me all the way here after everything.
Alright.
Okay, it comes from here.
Hold my gun!
They're like everywhere!
I need to find some heals real quick.
They're like everywhere.
They're like swarming me.
Yeah, I need to get armor and heal.
Okay, there.
Good.
God, there was heals here.
And now that I save here, I don't have to worry as much.
Okay, wants me to go that way, but I'm gonna make sure I
cleared the area first before I do anything.
Because I think it'll benefit me if I clear this up.
Start using the acid.
Okay, I need to get that and then grab this.
Alright, nice.
Alright, where are they?
movement oh give me a sec i'm reloading still movement
technically oh they're all dead nice all right i was just
worried about like maybe having to come back here later
there is an outsize that means i have to go outsize later
they're like retro fpds check out the Citadel series.
Think of a Super Chat.
Think of Thank you.
A national.
It depends on.
I guess it really depends.
I like this because I do love the art style for this.
I know there's like some people wanting me to check out like
the, what was it, the girlie retro shooter type?
I was like, bro, I can't see shit.
The graphics have to appeal me to.
The graphics and movement.
Because like, there's some Retro shooters?
That look fun.
But then I don't think I can look at it for too long.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, it's just like...
Like, I'm having, like, an eye seizure or whatever.
Like, I'm having a fucking seizure.
If I watch for it for too long.
Type deal.
Like, I'm on a fucking psychedelic trip.
That's my issues with some...
with some retro shooters.
They do like too much shit with the graphics.
Flacco, please, please, please.
Thank you, the super chat peddler.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, wait, I just went backwards.
I was curious where it led to.
Are you serious?
Okay, wait, I can fix this.
There we go.
Yeah, it still wanted to be like, visually appealing if i'm
one of if i'm playing a shooter just want to be sure if it's
breakable okay the strongest wood in existence made from
like a thousand year old trees infused with like titanium
all right here we go here
i don't know what they were trying to do oh oh well this guy
was smarter oh my god he's so shot me even even after death
what the fuck golden monkey what the fuck do I do with a
golden monkey what
I must have like done this Steve get a nice thing going then
let it ride without blinking what the fuck What do I do with
a golden monkey?
Where does this go?
But, um...
Yeah, the pedestal, but like, where the fuck is the
pedestal?
Two years is a hell-long stretch for war wounds to heal.
Most of them do, but this one.
Well, we could have had.
Me, Jack, or any tough call, sure.
Always is with POWs.
But we pulled through.
We always did.
They didn't call us the Invincible Trio for laughs, eh?
So much gold we could have lived like Rat King's.
Carpets this thick.
All for the price of you shallow graves.
At least Stilton keeps in touch more than can I say about.
The Invincible Trio.
Broken by a conscience.
Oh, shit!
Oh, there was a bug.
Did you guys see that?
I can open the thing, but...
The elf thing disappears afterwards.
Alright, nice.
Still don't know what to do with this.
Oh, what?
There's another one!
Hear no evil, see no evil, speak no evil.
Wait, now I have two of these.
What the fuck do I do with two of these?
Another monkey.
I'll put the monkeys here.
All right.
I have three monkeys now.
And the entrance go up to the end.
You go, right?
Where do these monkeys go?
Huh.
There's a back room in the library?
Oh!
Okay, that was not your...
Alright, there you go.
Oh, that's where the monkeys are.
Alright.
Am I missing?
Do I have to go down for the last monkey?
Where's the last monkey?
We need three monkeys.
Look at the last monkey be.
I hope the last one is down there.
I'll be ashamed if it wasn't.
Maybe it's down here.
No?
No monkey.
That's fine.
Where could the third monkey be?
There's a room on the by the entrance.
There is a room?
What room?
This...
I went... I opened that room.
I feel like the monkey it gives me the Funko Pop.
Where is the third monkey?
The monkey's jumping on the bed.
Monkey, monkey.
Oh, it's outside.
Well, I guess we're never getting that monkey.
Never mind.
Why is one monkey outside?
And the other two are, like, inside.
Who put the monkey outside?
Told them to clean up the room.
Told them toys cannot be outside.
Monkeys can't be outside.
Oh, I froze myself.
Of course I did.
all right oh okay we gotta find the missing lever
and nice we need that ammo
okay all right here you go the monkey escaped
how did that open how do i get out wait a minute oh oh okay
that was a They're a...
Portable freezer.
Oh, is that freeze ray?
Oh!
Freeze.
Yeah.
Oh!
Ooh!
I like this gun.
Oh, this is a good gun.
Wait, this is my new favorite gun.
Oh, yeah, that's nice.
That feels good.
Oh, and they finally came out.
And that's...
Oh, there's the sniper.
It's so tough now, are you?
all right now we gotta find the monkey monkey monkey where
could the monkey be yeah definitely won't use it against the
shrews though but I'll find the monkey in the maze he could
be anywhere I know it would be so proud he would be nice to
freeze you.
A monkey in here?
Guys, where's the monkey?
Guys said there would be a room on my side.
I don't see no monkey anywhere.
Monkey?
Oh, monkey!
Yay!
I can't wait to get my Funko Pop.
So, so sad that Funko Pop's going bankrupt.
We'll never get a jokie Funko Pop.
Oh?
Is that open?
Yeah.
They declare bankruptcy.
Oh, they open this.
Oh.
Well, on the creepy side.
But that's it.
I don't get my Funko Pop?
Oh, there it is.
I got it.
Yeah, so they're doing, like...
They're like going bank...
They declared bankruptcy a couple...
Uh, a while ago, I remember.
But they have, like, previous obligations.
Like, previous contracts and stuff that they have to uphold.
But they're not doing so well right now.
No, I asked my events manager.
about it.
Because she knows people at Funko, that works at Funko Pop.
And she said that, yeah, it's almost impossible to get a
contract right now with them.
Because, uh, because, you know, they're broke.
Yeah.
Fine.
A use for the stone hand requires a stone sphere.
Yeah, so it's unfortunate.
I talked about it before, but Yeah.
Good morning, Bobdrew.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Good morning to you too.
I think it's just it's because I'm late.
Oh, nice.
Unlock the shortcut.
It's like, I think like, it's because, like, Funko Pop is
sort of, it's a fad, you know, the, what the fuck you ran
away.
It's like Beanie Baby.
Eventually, the market will crash.
Oh?
Oh my god.
Guys, guys, one at a time.
One at a time, guys.
Oh my god, oh my god, get out of here.
Gotta get out of here.
Get out of here.
Oh, this is bad.
What the fuck is that?
Yeah, they got my, they got my ankles.
Oh my god, I like how he's eating spinach right here.
That was scary.
They were bashing my ankles, guys.
Oh, fuck.
I like the cheese.
Oh, I got you another cheese.
Oh, they're all shooting me.
That doesn't help.
Get this guy out of here.
Holy shit, he hit...
He was hitting headshots.
Yeah, Funko Pops lasted surprisingly longer than I expected.
Not gonna lie.
And it's just because they, like, just the amount of IPs
they have.
And I think FNAF saved them.
Not gonna lie.
I didn't even wasn't for FNAF.
They would have been fucked.
Because, like, they literally made majority of the FNAF
merch line.
I think for that, basically, like, kept them afloat.
The longest.
And we got the sphere.
We got the ponder, the orb thing.
And the NFT before NFT was a thing.
And he had so many IPs and...
Oh, what the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
This is no longer magic.
There's no way.
this is science good view high ground what we're missing is
your rifle we're missing one more gun must be from the end
of our tour you know it almost looks like we meant those
smiles why'd you hang on to it steve
oh there's the video the tape was incriminating evidence
against milford soyer dropping that We should blow this wide
open.
Just gotta find the right place.
Tape.
No label.
No manual.
I never would want at the World's Fair.
I'll piece it together on the way.
Ronda's waiting.
Yeah.
I think it's just that FNAF's popularity has been dying.
And like, they've, like, Scott has, has, like, signed
different partnerships with Merchant now.
So Funko Pop doesn't have, like, a Monopoly.
on FNAF merch.
On Five Nights at Freddy's merch anymore.
And then there's like other competitions now too.
And I think like, you know, like Has been Hotel has their
own, like, Has been Hotel glitch through their own merch
line.
A lot of like IPs now do their own merch line versus like
working with manufacturers.
The fuck?
Come here.
Hello?
Oh, never mind.
World's Fair.
I forgot my house is burning.
I can't go there.
I was like, hey, why can't I come back to my house?
Why can't I go home?
Oh yeah, my house has burnt down.
Oops.
Forgot about that.
I thought they put... I don't know.
I thought the firefighters put it out already.
Bang.
Oh, this is where I upgrade stuff.
Uh, we'll do the freeze.
I knew I saved it up a bit.
Actually, that's a good upgrade.
What?
Oh my god, it had the animation.
That's why.
Wait, can I freeze it in the air?
Okay, he just dies.
That makes sense.
Alright.
Off we go to meet Wanda.
I still think the James gun is the best.
Oh, in the 1930s, we've got a giant-ass airplane.
Oh my god, now I have to deal with robots, too?
Hello?
All right, goodbye.
He just...
He's just gonna live there forever.
I guess that's where he lives now.
Stuck in eternity.
Next to that box.
I broke it.
He broke his programming.
He doesn't know what to do anymore.
Someone reset him.
There's stuff in here.
How do I get in there?
Oh, there it is.
It's not really a secret when there's a door.
I crashed this DP.
You someone updated his GPU drivers say so save him
Oh, yeah, I knew there's stuff behind there's always stuff
behind
Yeah Easy
Oh Yes, easy
I'll get the ones flying first all right nice oh i heard
some flying over there who's over there flying all right i
don't need to worry about so i'll make sure i grab all the
loot here first
all right nope no secrets all right off i go what the fuck
was whipping oh okay that's It's okay.
He doesn't know.
He can look through bars.
Hey there.
See, that's why you're a goon.
And not a boss.
He's standing by.
Alright.
Me?
Oh, nice.
Just pour it one.
Me one more.
It's fine.
He doesn't get paid enough to care, Doki.
Leave him alone.
I mean, it's very odd.
I don't think he's paid enough to think.
That's for sure.
Alright, where are the rest?
Nice.
There anymore?
Oh my god.
My movement is so clean now.
Look at that.
Now I'm dooming.
Alright.
Right side, alright.
Gotta go this way for loot.
Oh, no loot.
Alright, I'm full HP too.
What is this for?
There is a hook up here.
Which means...
Oh, never mind.
It's not the swinging kind of hook.
Oh true doc hmm is there any secrets why I'm kind of in a
rush here I know I know places to be gadgets to buy but see
see me and my buddy here where yeah cargo jokes and let me
guess fell flat worse it landed right on top of him oh no we
need to lift it so we can get the door open you know saving
why can't you do it yeah i ain't exactly built for climbing
marcellus though he was real jumpy climby too kind of like
one of those animals i think he'll make it pretty sure but
out and proud i i think he made he's gonna make it what's
your monk hey now forget it where are the controls right
above us go get it buddy Those asylum cheese fumes do seem
to have some lasting effects.
Oh, yeah.
What kind of powers are that?
Oh, what?
What can I do now?
What the fuck was that?
Cosmo, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, oh, I can climb now.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay, only on the yellow paint.
All right, that makes sense.
Yep.
sense.
They only climb on the yellow paint.
That's where I was given approval to climb on.
I don't know.
Yep, of course.
That's where legally it was marked.
It's where they got the licenses for.
You know?
You know how like you need certain licenses to Like certain
spots that are marked for that you can climb on Oh my god
from one safety the next
Yeah, you need a permit exactly The permit only applies to
boxes where with yellow paint or white paint on
All right, is he alive?
Oh, look see I told you he'd live look at that I told you
he'd make it
Okay, got, yeah, you got permit to climb that ledge?
That's right, you can't climb on this ledge.
That's, you're gonna get arrested.
Only pre-approved ledges, guys.
Or the government's gonna get you.
But it's okay, I have a permit for this ledge.
Not this one, though.
That's illegal.
Built like a flat ass.
Looks like he's alright.
Look at him.
healthy wow man you sure are he got a license for that ledge
just like one of those um what was it monkeys yeah of course
no illegal climbing here you're still a pancake but hey the
deal's a deal jesus jesus grace don't worry
i believe
$2,000 of medical bills will fix you up We can we can
inflate him in no time
Wait, is that a robot sniper?
Oh my god, it is I didn't even notice it
No, God's not real.
He's not gonna help you In front of Jesus, don't he?
My dad's It's not real?
But we can inflate them.
There ya.
All right.
Bump, bump, bump, bump.
Bump, bump.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
Where are they?
Oh shit, reload.
Alright, we gotta Use this for this guy.
Ooh, easy.
Oh hey, look, the elephant has a It's a little hat.
My hat now.
Yeah, I love I love the movement when I have the space to do
it.
It's so fun.
Like, when you do have the space, it's fucking fun as hell.
That's why I hate it when they put me in, like, a confined
area, where I just stand in a corner and wait for them to
come over.
It's really nice when they actually give me an open, like,
an open area to move around in.
And that's where the game shines the most.
Less of the underwater levels.
More of this.
The underwater level was fucking ass.
The underwater, I don't know what the fuck they were
thinking about that underwater level.
level.
Like, that shit was so ass.
This one is a real gem.
The very first edition ever printed.
Straight out of the 19th century, just four pages long.
It's mostly filled with advertisements and obituaries.
Still, the earlier-in-chief probably promises to build in
this humble beginning and bring good, engaging journalism to
all citizens of Malaspiria and beyond.
Oh, have three cents!
Holy shit!
that paper better be printed in gold yeah the underwater
with permanent selfie mode was definitely not it
there always will be an underwater level the sheer amount of
bullets i had to unload just to get to you well aren't you
sweet jack so you got the evidence sure do steve added
stashed in his mansion it's a tape recording of some sort
tape recording huh bet there's a confession on it.
Get it to my editor-in-chief.
He's hanging around the VIP lodge second floor.
I'm gonna have to go down to Blimp, aren't I?
Oh, yay!
Sun party!
I'm gonna go grab some water real quick.
I need to refill the water.
Alright.
I got water.
I don't know why games have to have an underwater level.
On that first thing, it was Super Chat thinking, thank you.
like, it makes your game worse if you include it.
Can I party a little bit before I do all of this?
The future is in the future.
Ooh, what even is this 2.0?
Original replica to the real Miles Fink's nose.
Oh, it's the nose.
Antique chamber pot.
Oh, Mishu Mushi.
Blaned?
Can't quite put my finger on it.
Game dev what it's like they're like we can't publish your
gate like steam it's like what if it's like an inside job It
all goes to the top with steam seems like we won't publish
your game unless you have an underwater level Because Gabe
loves the ocean and he's like every game must have an
underwater level
For those who don't know, Gabe lives on the ocean right now.
He's like, he's just chilling in the ocean, studying ocean
sea life.
Gabe, what the fuck?
Seam requires water to operate.
Wait a minute, she's on to something.
There are a handful of good ones, but a few and far between.
Donkey Kong Country, add them.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, he has a John ass yacht and he just lives in the ocean
studying marine life
It's not conspiracy theory.
It's the truth It all goes all the way to game Every game
must have an underwater level as decreed by by sir game
Okay, a real ocean man That's cool.
I like that Oh I was supposed to go there.
I just want to explore a little bit before I talk I thought
talking here starts the whole thing You done sightseeing
let's move it chop chop You done sightseeing let's I'm
really talking to you you have the giant you done
sightseeing?
Let's move it Oh, apparently I'm not done sightseeing never
mind So I have to go there
All right, I do have to go there.
And coincidence?
I think not.
What are they up to in there?
All right.
It's over here.
Oh, I have to go here.
Then there's another way.
Oh, money.
Yeah.
It's all connected, guys.
have shitty underwater levels it's mandatory that they want
their game on steam and that's why it's always so half-ass
almost every one oh I can't go through that
okay I think God we have a permit to climb here it's
pre-approved by the government ledge climbing the ledge
climbing district and then my belly like this and then you
like that this fuse just got blown gotta get back to
That villain.
Every game must have it.
Wait, what the fuck?
That just walked backwards?
Oh, I did.
I was like, wait a minute.
This doesn't seem right.
Alright, now I'm here.
Oh, now she's here, too.
Oh, I don't want to go up.
About a week ago, I saw you climb the eternity I'm inspired.
Inspired and climbed hard.
It took seven days to climb from GM3 to journey.
Oh, congratulations.
Guys, I'm so proud of you.
Congratulations.
Is there a first time in eternity?
That's so cool.
Are you able to do it?
I'm proud.
Totally legit moon model.
Way food tasting.
Seems about right.
Seems real.
Mouse in a bath.
job.
Yeah, great job.
Cheesy Joker.
Cradle.
Blush fineness.
My future prize.
That one.
I like that one.
That's me.
Dried for our fin.
Dried for our fins.
Does that some Timmy Turner shit?
Timmy's dad stuff.
Right there.
Am I mute to cereal canners?
So, did you do it?
But, did you know your boss is doing cheese shots off the
party members' bellies?
What?
Yeah, he's real cozy with the BMP.
Belly button cozy.
You know it that...
Great.
Just great.
Guess I'll have to quit the Herald now.
And there's no other daily worth a damn.
Well, there is mainly Mouse Weekly, but...
Penning fluff for peanuts.
It's a...
And that office reeks of Gorgonzola.
Wanda, hey.
What?
The tape.
What do we do with it?
I don't know, Jack.
It all sounds so...
Oh, sound?
Right.
Sawyers making the rally public.
Through some kind of a experimental broadcast.
Vision and sound.
Oh, sound?
All powered by this World Fair's inventions.
And yep, all runs on a tape player.
Perfect.
It's never going to make it.
It's never going to...
There's a sound booth right above the BMP rally grounds.
Used to be for devil song karaoke or something.
Now it's for mastering audio.
There's no way.
Sound and TV?
There's no way that's going to get anywhere.
It's crazy, Ty.
Next, you're going to tell me people are going to stop
reading.
reading on television.
No way.
They'll never catch on.
Sound, yeah.
This sounds like a fad, guys.
You're going to tell me that radio's going to die.
It's crazy time.
What's next?
Watching movies at home?
Fucking crazy.
How am I gonna get popcorn at home?
How am I gonna, how am I gonna get popcorn?
On that Tanya screen, watching a movie on a Tanya screen?
Let's not get realistic.
I never had crazy talk.
It's all just gonna be offensive dialed soon.
TV with sound.
Who's gonna play?
Who's gonna play the piano?
What would the piano man do at the theater?
If we have sound.
On our movies.
What are you gonna do?
Think about the piano man.
You guys know that?
In theaters, they would have a portable piano man that plays
for the movie.
So it's not actually like...
Like there's no like actual music and now everyone's upset
that I'm bringing something in the super chat that you
think.
Yeah, the guy on piano plays next to a silent film because
you know it's supposed to be silent.
So the funny music that you hear on silent films, that's the
portable piano man.
That's why it's called silent film.
That's looking crazy.
I won't- I- Can't- I won't believe it until I see it.
TV- audio and visual.
My silent film is a little silent.
I'll see it till I believe it.
What the fuck?
Okay, I thought you died.
What is that sound?
Oh, it's the robot.
oh wait there's a that would be helpful actually oh
what the fuck
oh my god just beep beep beep beep beep oh
my god there's the sniper I was like wondering where I'm
taking damage okay let's see is there any metal hats any
hats for me Or the hats.
Aww.
Alright, that should be everything.
I can't believe it.
They already invented AI to take our jobs.
Oh, there we
go.
They have AI to take our Hitman jobs now?
Think about the Hitman!
How would they provide to their...
Do the family...
I don't usually have no family.
I can't even justify it.
How would it provide for the wife that's in witness
protection right now?
They're hit families.
They're mafia family.
Think about the mafia, guys.
The poor mafia, men and women.
Damn, so cute hitmen can't be family, man.
How do you know that?
How many hitmen do you know to have the families, huh?
What?
So I'm back again.
We were so close.
I'm almost to the finished live.
We were doing so well.
Oh my god.
Come on, PC.
Take me there.
We're back again.
We're almost there.
Just a little more.
And then we'll fucking try to fix you.
Most likely.
Most likely I got a stress test tomorrow.
I'll fix it.
I'll do like stuff to fix it.
Because I streamed the entire day.
It's been like more.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Hide and hide.
Oh my god.
All the way here too.
again he's like right here there you go there we go i don't
know why i crouch i crouch shot him like i was on playing cs
there oh yeah but i have to kill the hitman again kill him
again
his poor family that's oh yeah at least i didn't i didn't
see this place though.
It's poor family and witness protection.
Meaning I can't wait till daddy finishes the job and then
we'll, we can be back together again.
Daddy never returns home.
Whoa!
It's lagging.
It's frame dropping like crazy though.
The drop shop instinct.
Okay.
I gotta count for the count for the bullet drop and the
recoil.
All right, I gotta fix that.
I do not like that.
All right, graphics.
Maybe I'll go high.
Should I have been asking questions about the family
business?
Why is it like that?
Since I might have to restart it again.
Feels so weird.
Where's my friend?
right I'm like frame dropping here oh my god it's two of
them
oh it's so I don't know if you guys notice it but but it's
like frame dropping a little oh oh oh my I hate it I hate it
There's like frame tears and stuff It's not as it's not
smooth for me right now.
It's suit.
Okay, wait I need to get to a save point Where's the where's
the typewriter?
I Need a typewriter set
Yeah, it's like I'm at yeah, I'm gonna restart this game
This game might have a memory leak maybe I've never seen so
I just don't want to do that run again And you find a
typewriter quick We're the fuck on a type and give me 80
typewriters before and now I get zero There's no way There's
no way I got like 80 fucking typewriters and then now I have
none I don't checkpoint task manager nope everything is fine
on task manager side it's like yeah everything seems fine
over there he took the typewriter oh i'll
just put the tape seat from me especially not a rat oh
please that guy's
getting overpriced it's soft wow you sure are sharp i'm real
excited what do i got from
the agora to the movies from the old this one features an
article a military story a politician turned actor after
more than a few heated arguments with fellow party member
sawyer threw in the town made the leap to tinsel Avenue to
try his luck in the film industry.
Luckily, it didn't happen the other way around, right?
Yeah, that's fun.
We gotta find us a typewriter stat.
I really need to save my game.
What?
Where's my gun?
Oh,
Okay, oh, there's my gun.
I just got beat up for free, I guess.
I was like, why did this guy run up to me?
I was like, hey there.
What's going on?
What do you want, guys?
Is it a party?
freaking guy free knuckle sandwich with my name on it
apparently oh well where's the party at everybody where the
is the typewriter there's no way there's no way and you
ain't going anywhere because guess what we've got someone oh
is he the bad guy someone real close to your cold ticker
what thank gumshoe who do you care about most you're the
closest thing i got to a dad oh tammy understanding last
warning pepper one more step and off goes the head i swear i
was gonna say me me i still can't believe it like the one at
the time I actually need a typewriter and then no typewriter
it was like typewriter for days dude for
damage boom oh it doesn't work that's why I'm gonna punch
you just because you can fly you think I'm not gonna hit you
Okay.
Alright, we are running out.
We use shotgun now.
Alright, about this.
First they'll kill them.
Then I cuff them.
In that order.
Do anyone below me?
No.
Can they reload?
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I fell down.
It doesn't not blow up?
Okay, it does.
Okay.
It's just shotgun proof, apparently.
It has the strongest bullet-proof vest.
I know I don't have to, but it's to send a message.
Oh wait, I did have to.
Never mind.
Never mind, guys.
I did have to shoot it.
Yeah, it was apparently shotgun proof.
Oh!
We made it.
Now, time to move.
All right.
Typewriter?
Typewriter.
Okay, okay, it's fine.
I don't need a typewriter at this point.
Alright.
This should be a save point, right?
This has to be a save point, guys, right?
I just want to fix the fucking frame job.
Oh my god, we're almost at the end.
Alright, well, just to be safe, I'm gonna find a typewriter.
It was a long stretch, and I was starting to get serious
Just to be safe.
Typewriter?
A typewriter?
Oh my god, we're back here.
Wait, we're back here!
We're back in the tutorial!
I don't know how to do this.
Wait, yeah, it's the tutorial level.
Wait, was it a flashback the entire time?
Oh my god, I forgot.
We were in the flashback, right?
Oh my god, Typewriter.
Alright, we're gonna restart the game.
I'm gonna restart it.
It all comes full circle.
Yeah, it's like, how did we get here?
Scenario.
Yeah, story beginning at the end.
detective shit oh my god so we actually did know the villain
that was the villain the entire time
you might be wondering how i got here all right let's see
let me see what's it better now oh what the fuck i think
there's a member in the somewhere
Yeah, he was the villain all on.
Wait, I'm trying.
I'm fine.
Alright.
There has to be a memory leak somewhere.
It's like, I can tell that
something's off.
My frame is feeling doo-doo here.
Yeah.
Alright, let's see.
Oh!
my god please please mouse pi oh
no okay let's let's see if i can do this
it's like all right it's manageable yeah i think i might
need a reboot all right guys to reboot for the final
oh oh my god it's so gross
All right, all right, let me...
I can't kick that door.
All right, let me do this.
Crack the code.
One last reboot for the ride.
But let me do this real quick.
Okay, wait, wait, did it fix itself?
Try to see if it fixed itself.
No, I can see the stutter.
Oh!
Oh, it hurts so much.
It hurts even more because it's like, it's a movement shoot.
It's movement game.
It's a, oh wait, what the fuck?
It's a movement, wait, actually I think it, maybe it fixed
itself here.
It's a movement game, so it's like super noticeable.
All right, wait, actually I think it, it like crashed
itself, so maybe I fixed itself.
So I'm like, it's no longer smooth.
I can't deal with that.
I'm trying to do that cool movement shit.
I'm going to double check.
If it's not smooth anymore, I don't know where to start.
God, we're so close to it.
This is like Pragmata all over again.
It's like Pragmata all over again.
No, I can feel it.
I don't know if you guys can feel it.
Oh, yeah, that's like mini-studders.
It's the curse.
It's the pragmatic.
I'll never...
I'll never update my drivers ever again.
Yeah, alright.
I'm gonna restart my...
Yeah, I'm gonna restart my PC.
I'll be right back.
One last restart for the ride.
Oh, my God.
Dad, please.
one last restart and then we're at we're at the finish line
oh my god no no no no he like ran up to me because i was
ignoring him all right yeah no he he like ran up to me and
started breaking at the door at my door all right one last
restart and four the ride.
We're almost there, guys.
I'll be right back.
Oh.
Hello.
Hello, everyone.
We're back.
Oh, it's smooth again.
Yeah, there was definitely a memory leak somewhere.
Yeah, we're smooth now.
Oh, my God, we're back.
There was definitely a memory leak somewhere.
Everything is so smooth now, guys.
Oh, it's just so much better.
Yeah, we got the movement.
All right, back at it again.
You got nowhere left to run.
Back at it, I'm scared.
I want the dream.
A bright future ruled by big vice.
Oh, you absolute hate.
Uh, hell.
All right, here we go again.
Okay.
Oh, Everything I learned.
That's right.
Oh, my God.
I didn't actually use the shotgun for this.
Oh, and then...
Ass attack.
We're almost there.
We're almost at the finish line.
Nice.
Oh, no, not the big guy.
Actually, I could kill him with the shotgun.
Oh, what the fuck?
Jesus, how many shots does it take?
Oh, I ran out.
I actually ran out.
Oh, look at that growth.
That character arc.
I remember when I died to die on the day.
Oh, that's what I have.
potion oh we're doing it so close to the end oh just like
last time
all right use brain gun bring in this yeah not that strong I
am though I don't use it just Because the other guns are
better.
What?
Blowing your brain.
My brain.
I do remember.
Yeah, I was like, I remember there was a save here.
Oh.
I knew there was a secret nearby.
I don't know.
Your brain.
Alright, no more brain.
Good old James gun.
reliable.
And then there was a secret down here.
There was a secret up here.
Well, the secret was just money, but money is considered a
secret sometimes.
You know, sometimes money can be considered a secret.
If you're hiding something.
Alright, here you go.
and then there's a save
nice blueprint
i'm back again i'm so we're so close we're so
close and we're literally almost there i just i can't even
make another part i can't even postpone this because we're
literally right at the finish line we're right at the finish
line and then and the tsunami's hitting they're like think
again we're almost there we're almost there please like it's
like sorry the race is We're having a natural disaster right
now that has hit that has hit our area where I have to
postpone like no please we're right here I'm literally two
sets away from the finish line please just let me cross the
finish line I just I need to see the end just let me see see
the ending.
I don't care if you hit me right after.
I just...
Oh my god.
Surprise, earthquake.
Sorry, wrap it up, folks.
Wrap it up.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my God.
I just want to see the cheese at the end of the tunnel.
That's all I want.
Okay.
Alright.
All right.
Here we go again.
Here.
Tokeyford versus the Vega verse.
Please, please, please, please see.
Just, just a little longer, and then I'll take you to the
hospital.
Please.
You just don't worry.
I know your leg is broken and you're bleeding out.
But please, just a little longer.
I'll take you to the hospital right after.
I swear.
I just need to finish this game you can bleed out for 10
more minutes okay 10 more minutes and then i'll take you to
the hospital and get you a trap a blood transfusion i'll oh
eight
i know i know your leg is broken there's an open wound a lot
of blood is pulling out pouring out right now but just 10 to
15 more minutes that's all i asked for and then I'll take
you to the hospital and we'll get it all we'll get it all
looked at right after it's not don't worry it's not that bad
it'll be okay I don't even think the wound is that deep
anyway you know the human body can carry surprisingly a lot
of amount of blood I think you'd be okay I think you can
lose a bit around 30 more minutes of blood and we should be
good we should be fine 10 to 15 minutes more.
Bite this towel.
Here, have this towel and bite on it real quick.
Wait.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
We're just there.
I'm so sorry.
I know it's so annoying.
It's very annoying to me too.
I'm so sorry.
I'm really sorry for the quality of today's stream.
Look.
that leg, but you still have another leg.
That's why God gave us two legs.
One is expendable.
one, who?
We have one extra.
It's a plus one, just in case we break the other.
Oh, and you're for, and Sal, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Take peace.
You go need to go to the ICU.
Papa, do you have a super chat.
Thank you.
Really putting the edge of the edge of glory.
Don't eat, dear.
Okay, all right.
Okay, let me double check everything.
I even put it on high and everything.
All right.
Where am I?
Where am I in this level?
Oh, my God.
Here we go again.
Oh, you had to send me all the way back here.
It's okay.
We will make it super fast.
I will speedrun this.
Okay.
we're speed running just hang on a little longer okay
oh my god we don't need any of the money we don't need to do
safe lock okay just just stay alive oh hey okay just now
stay alive
okay okay we're almost there we have to do the lockpicks we
have to keep going bc bc good we have to do this lockpicks
oh my god okay there you go save wait wasn't there another
save back here oh well never mind guess not guess not we're
just going straight here so yeah hell he's way too far i can
hear you just fine you meddling mouse engines and the wind
don't care fair enough i'll be there in a blink all right
okay here we go
all right we have to use this
oh my god drink up drink up
oh i'm going as fast as i can right now of course he's right
above me all right Next stage
I've never played it I'm not doing fancy moves no more Oh
this is where we ended There it is This is where we ended
the tutorial part Okay Oh my god It's tails With pleasure
Survive the BMP awesome Alright no more fancy ass movement
We're just playing the game Okay
We're just shooting now!
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Oh, oh, okay, we're supposed to be here.
Hiring what?
These?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Sorry, it's still a speedrun, guys.
I just got a little confused.
Don't worry, it's still a speedrun.
I was just like, what?
Okay, okay, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
I don't know what happened.
I just, I don't know what happened, okay?
Guys, guys, okay.
Okay, I don't know what happened there.
I sort of slipped and fell.
Alright, speedrun starts now.
Speedrun starts now.
Please, please, please, please.
PC, I just need you to Please, PC.
You see it?
I'll stop moving.
I'll just stay still.
You gotta survive We'll reload just in case
All right She's still alive for a little longer
Yeah Let me reload.
Let me reload dammy
Oh my god, the goddamn sniper Is he dead?
Alright, we made it.
We're so close.
Just keep on.
Oh.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Fucking course.
Okay.
Everything is good.
It's good.
Everything is fine.
We eat the cheese.
And then we chunk this down.
Where are they all coming from?
Oh no.
Okay.
We're almost there!
He's there, we're almost there!
Just stay alive!
I'll take you to the hospital right after!
Okay, he didn't, he was bluffing, he was bluffing.
Yeah, he's got joy!
Genius!
We haven't heard from him!
He's there, he gets the clock right now!
Close to my heart
Okay, I'm here.
Thank God.
Thank God they transported me
I'm ready.
I'm ready BMP We're a stupid politician.
That guy's got stamina.
I'll give him that
Okay Just to make sure oh my god, they got me everything we
got the save too it's the final countdown we're all here
okay all right is any upgrade one final upgrade for the road
uh nope let's go it's the final countdown the trap mouse all
right soya this is it the end of the line and i'd if it
weren't for you, you meddling mouse.
Nah, not without curd feeding you orders.
A puppet's just dead wood without a pulling hand.
Are you doing so good?
Are you so good, Pissy?
Pissy, cool, you're doing amazing.
We're almost here.
The finish line is here.
Because let's face it, Soria, you couldn't scheme your way
out of a running wheel.
You're just not that smart.
Uh, you, you, you, you, why won't you just die already?
Oh God, oh, I am stubborn and you you're out of time
How am I
okay, I assume I have to
All right, let's see
Okay Wait, it's not oh here Where am I supposed to shoot?
all right it's fine it's fine it's fine
oh my brain juice use the brain juice
oh no more ammo
oh please tell me okay that should be it
okay all right what do i shoot now
Okay, pattern time, pattern, pattern, pattern.
All right.
What the fuck?
Okay, here.
Oh, that's what it's for.
Okay.
All right.
No, I can't.
It's a barrier.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
whoa whoa whoa there you go you made it
what wait what the fuck what what what am I doing stop him
before he wrecks everything okay everything is okay channel
your inner rest in evil.
Oh, God.
Oh, there's so many.
Oh, my God.
Okay, we're going down.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I ran out.
Oh, please.
There we go.
Oh, fuck, come on, bro.
Jesus, please.
Okay.
You know, I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna zap.
I know there's one more.
Oh, my god.
It's just...
There's so many things.
Casey, please.
Stay strong.
There's just so many things on my screen.
Just stay strong!
He's so low!
Oh, we got him!
We got him!
Don't crash!
BMP is corrupt?
I am so shocked!
Oh, God, not yet.
Okay.
I got full spectrum.
and they're gonna shine all right well he's consistent I'll
give him that okay thread the needle
all right
okay it's just that one area oh what is this oh that took
that boy
this got real old real fast whoa whoa whoa whoa
Oh my god, I have to...
Oh my god, this is actually bullshit.
What am I...
No!
What?
What is this?
Oh my god!
Oh!
What am I looking at?
Okay, it's fine.
I got the health pack.
It's actually not fine.
Oh, there is no more HP.
What happens, happens?
Are you fucking...
How?
Oh my god, they refilled.
Wait, they refilled the health packs.
Oh, thank guy.
I don't know when they did it, but they refilled everything.
Enough of all this, you damn mouse.
Oh, little stunt changes.
nothing you hear nothing will break BMP time to end this
nightmare rally oh my almost forgot the cheese I don't know
who came over and refilled it but thank you sir
BMP BMP oh my god I'll be sick just a little longer I know I
said five minutes ten minutes ago ten more ten five minutes
more you five more minutes to save Five more minutes, PC
code.
We're almost there.
You have so much blood inside you.
No, I should be using this event.
All right.
All right, it's fine.
Carefully.
We're almost there.
Stay strong.
There's literally one!
There we go!
Oh, we made it!
Okay, one more guy!
Oh!
We got him!
Now I gotta clean this up myself!
Last one!
Last boss!
Milford next!
What the fuck?
How did he get so big?
Okay.
It's actually acid meta.
What the fuck?
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god, I'm like, stop.
Please!
I'm
trying But there's so many ads There's so many ads spam
This is so bullshit
Oh my god
It's so hard Because it's like I'm trying to shoot him
I'm throwing acid He's throwing bodies what
Jesus Christ all
right at least like he's just friendly fire at least thank
God
I swear to God
oh please we're so close there's
so many bodies BNB
what oh we did end of the line oh just shut your damn mouth
thank God we're friendly fire oh thank God he's low get him
that's right found oh it'll be okay my body will be okay i
made it right saw you later pal that was that was just crap
i can use it burn that one time to finish him for pc code
oh he did it you did good you did so good you did so good we
made it we fucking We made it.
John, you still in one piece?
You did good PC.
You did good PC, Koot too.
Man, hell of a tale to tell over some melted cheese, huh?
Well don't jinx it.
We're still on a ticking blimp.
Saw some EVAC planes in the back when they dragged me in.
But hey, did we win?
Is this thing finally over?
It's over.
I see the finish line.
They said they're going to reschedule the race.
I begged I was on my knees I was like, please I trade all
day for this race And they're like Ma'am, there is a typhoon
7 warning right now No one's going to be there I was like
No, I must finish the race You can't stop me I will be there
no matter what If something happens to me You are liable.
So you better be there.
Because I'm going to finish that race.
We did it.
Holy, you did it.
Oh my god.
It's over.
Oh, he fucking He did great I'll take you to the hospital
now I think you lost Tooth there's blood But don't worry God
gave us two legs For a reason What We still have one Over
the other Oh, Karen, we were rewarded For Caravan Palace
What the hell That'll do, PC Koon.
That'll do.
Oh my god.
Took his chest as well.
And he's still, and the heart is still beating.
Oh my god.
I'm just happy.
I'm happy we made it to the end.
But PC Koon will be remembered.
You can rest now.
I will figure out what the fuck is going on.
Blazing, thank you for the 20 gift.
Oh my god, he does.
Thank you for the 20 gift of chips.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
We can rest now.
I'm just happy we beat the game.
We raced against the clock.
What were there other crashes, by the way?
What was it?
Or other extreme crashes.
I remember it from the Combeini one today.
Combeini.
Pragmata.
Was there any other ones?
Like today, both Combeini and also the Combeini and I just
want to count it just to be sure.
Like the full stream PC.
I want to know which days was it.
Which days was it?
The Vampire Crawler had a full stream crash.
yesterday.
I mean, like, yesterday?
Yeah, but yesterday wasn't a full stream crash, was it?
Did it do a...
I don't remember, guys.
Like, my PC issues have all...
have all blurred together.
Just...
Okay, what about full stream crash?
Has there any...
Is there any any any full stream crashes?
since Pragmata, other than this, other than today, uh...
We had it on...
Did we have it on...
Did we do a full stream crash?
With...
Uh...
With P.I.
Mouse?
Mouse P.I.
Last time?
I don't remember.
Did we?
Because I remember we...
I don't know if it was our game crash during the scene or it
was a stream crash I can't remember it it was only today
what about the PI mouse stream um with the witch did I crash
there I don't remember if I did or was that game crash it's
all blurry all the crashes are blurring together now I can't
remember every crash is blurring together for me it was just
there was too many to count
Alright, Dad, you want me to pick you up?
Give me a sign, I'm gonna pick him up.
He keeps thinking I'm giving him food.
He keeps thinking I'm gonna give him more food.
But he's like, he's like, no.
Like, he's like, I'm like, no.
I just want to pick you up.
And then he fucking runs into his little doghouse.
He doesn't want upbies.
He just runs into his doghouse.
Okay, because, like, I have, like, three cans out, like,
from the last three days, because I'm throwing it, I just,
I'm throwing it out, yeah, because I need to put a trash bag
on my trash can, um, and he thinks they're full, so he keeps
looking up at them, I think that's why, I think he's barking
because he thinks there's food in those, uh, in those dog
cans, but I'm like, you ate them, they're empty, they're
fucking empty, why are you looking at these empty cans,
solid, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, PC Kuhn still hospital bill and a new brother adoption
fund.
Congrats on completing the game.
I swear I might I might have to I might have to start
looking into a dual PC setup soon.
I can't this might be my the final solution actually if that
doesn't fix my problem when I do a dual PC setup I think I'm
just cursed guys.
I was You're like you are now going to be a streamer, but
then you'll be plagued with PC issues for your entire career
It's actually a fucking monkey paw situation right now your
entire PC issue is gonna be a fucking meme It'll never get
better No, I never have us called please you're not calling
the final solution this will be you see cool you're gonna
get you're gonna become a brother you're gonna become a big
brother double the PC double the problem that actually might
be how it's gonna go I would be like what we're gonna have a
problem I'm gonna have to figure out which PC it is.
I was like, which one is it?
Now I have to tech support both of them?
Like,
hey sir, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congratulations, Doki, on beating the game.
After so many issues came up, here's $5 towards your
exorcism to get that curse off you or therapy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Neppers, good job, Doki.
That was a long term.
Let's get mad when my Game crashes.
Leave a super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, but we made it.
We persevered.
We're strong.
We made it, guys.
We are strong.
We proved our way to victory.
It was a whole 12-hour.
Technically, I've had a 12-hour day, guys.
From the first stream to today, we've basically been live
for 12 hours.
of you of you who count if you add the earlier stream oh but
we missed so okay i just never no we oh we never we haven't
had any stream crashes other than pragmata just to double
check for everybody are there any other stream crashes that
we have i just got no just for like reference sake yeah i'm
gonna rest to tomorrow Julia, thank you for the super chat,
thank you, thank you.
The Dokey Bird PC situation is crazy.
Pragmata was a stream crash.
I had a stream crash on Pragmata, but that was after I
updated drivers.
Pragmata was a stream crash.
Today?
Okay, Pragmata and today.
Okay, the others were just game crashes.
Okay, that's good to know.
The others were just game crashes.
I've also, I don't know if you guys noticed too, but like,
after the driver's update, I also crash, like, uh, my skin
suit crashes too, sometimes, which I've also noticed.
So it depends on whether it's, uh, so I'm gonna look into
that and see what we have to do.
Whoa, yeah.
Um, so yeah, we're gonna check, we're gonna figure that out.
Yeah, I don't know if it happened a lot.
do I like do you mean like uh freeze where it crashes and I
have to restart it or like just buffering type deal what
was it like buffering oh it's just restart yeah oh losing
frames oh it's buffer okay oh just this stream okay it was
only this stream okay yeah I think it's literally just PC
Koon is not doing okay.
He might have caught that.
He might have been on a cruise recently.
He might have been on a cruise recently and flew straight
back home.
So we're gonna figure that out today.
Okay.
I'm gonna figure it out today.
We might have a little stress test stream tomorrow or maybe
the day after tomorrow.
We're gonna try and fix I'm gonna try and fix this problem
with my friend with my friends my tech friends Um, anyway,
guys, we did it guys.
We made it.
I'm gonna close the game just in case I crash In the while
I'm trying to just in case I it does One last job for the
ride, you know One last crash To end it all Um, but thank
you all for coming.
We finally beat mouse pi for higher it was it felt like a
fucking marathon all the way to the end it was truly a
journey at the end i felt like i they tied like eight to
eight hundred ton weight weights on my legs and you're like
come on you just just five more steps to the finish line
toky you got it but it was fun i really enjoyed this game i
really like the movement i love the story um i love the and
everything um the last boss was fucking crazy i think i i
will say my my i would say like my issues with the game um
like pros and cons cons um i i did not like the color
contrast sometimes because uh sometimes it's just gray yeah
also i did it on extra hard mode by the way i played on the
hardest mode they gave me.
So even then, I think if I played it on normal difficulty,
it would have been way too easy.
Because like, extra hard just felt like normal to me.
It didn't feel that difficult at all.
When I played it on extra hard, it really just felt like
normal difficulty.
So I feel like if I played on normal, I would have finished
it even.
I would have just killed everything super fast.
Um, um, uh, anyway, but uh, The, no, I just think like, I
think the game for extra hard difficulty, I think it doesn't
account for the fact that I think it was the movement that
saved me a lot.
I think if I played it, you know, I did extra hard
difficulty and I moved normally, like, you know, I just
moved side to side, like not jumping around, dashing around,
changing spots all the time and also not headshotting
because I was headshotting everything too.
So, like, I think that also helps with the fact that I was
able to breeze through the game a lot faster.
But, yeah, I think if I played on normal, it would have been
way too easy for me.
So, I'm glad I did extra hard.
Like I said, I think my biggest issue was just the color
grading.
I think the hardest part of this game, just trying to make
sure my PC doesn't die.
That's really it.
Honestly, the difficulty for...
where the difficulty shine was just making sure my pc
doesn't crash that's where it gets that's where it was the
hardest um but yeah i didn't really like the color contrast
that much because i felt like it could have been the
background sent to like blur do much together in a way where
like i couldn't find things sometimes because everything was
just gray uh everything was like gray and so i felt like it
would have been a lot better if there was more contrasting
black and white like uh because it's a norah game um but i
do love the movement pros i love the movement i love the
music it was very fun um it was very fun like jumping around
dashing and uh using all that well i didn't really use all
the guns i just found james guns james guns truly carried me
all the way to the end It was definitely my crutch to the
end there Just pop pop pop just headshots all the time With
that gun Yeah, some interactives were very hard to spot
Anyway, the story was good I really like the story, I love
the music Like I said, the last boss fight I did not like it
I did not like the last boss fight I think the last boss
fight, maybe it's just because I'm on extra hard, but the
last boss fight was a little poorly designed in a way
because all the other boss fights were really interesting,
but the last one was quite, I don't know, for me it was like
not as interesting as the other boss fights.
I think also like, um, um, which one was, I think.
I don't know.
It was just, they just, yeah.
It just, it just, it just felt like random bullshit.
That's really it.
They're just like, here's everything.
Survive.
And then the thing is, it would have been more fun if I had
a bigger map to go around.
Yeah, it was very spam-y.
Yeah, it's like, they're like, here's 800 mice.
survive like also you gotta shoot him too don't forget to
shoot the guy as well like here's 800 mice but also you
gotta shoot me whoa and they don't stop coming it felt like
a kingdom hearts fight when you're fighting the heartless in
the like the endless pit of heartless um but yeah um that's
how it felt for me um yeah i'm glad there was friendly fire
uh but i the brain gun would I don't know.
I think, like, I didn't like the last boss fight only
because, oh, yeah, I said I did a lot of heavy lifting
there.
It actually carried me through that fight, if I didn't have
the right click for it.
But I didn't like it because it limited me in that tiny ass
circle, too.
So I couldn't, like, move around as much as I would like,
compared to the other boss fights that I had.
The other boss fight was, like, moving around, jumping
around, shooting.
And there were some that were super easy.
The sniper one was way too easy.
they gave me like like fucking pillars to just hide behind
some boss fights are way too easy and then some were just
random bullshit um i there were like i like the i like the
robot fight i like the robot bosses the the robot girlfriend
bosses were fun um that one was pretty memorable and um and
it was another one it was the one i there were two boss
fights that particularly like uh the other ones were i think
the final boss was like pretty mad for me just because i was
like it just felt like it felt very cobbled together i guess
uh it felt very cobbled together in a way um where it didn't
feel like they had a plan on what they wanted what they
wanted to do
next thing thank you the super chat thank you thank you um
but yeah other than that i think that other than that i
think the mechanics are really fun the movement was fun um
the story was great the characters were interesting um and i
liked how you know we're trying to piece everything together
with all the different side missions and everything with all
the different levels and so yeah i just felt like the last
boss fight felt a little bit lazy um but yeah so that's all
my thoughts for the game um honestly a great time though i
will give i think i'll give the rating maybe like an 8 out
of 10 um 8 out of 10 or like a 7 to 8 that's around there um
around the range for the how for the game um in general um
but i like the references too the references and love letter
to um to all different types of video games and stuff music
is amazing i fucking love the music.
It's so good.
Um, but yeah.
Hey guys.
I'm gonna head off now.
As always, everybody.
Say hi.
Oh yeah, I hate the gliding.
What felt, the gliding felt like something they just want.
I don't know.
The gliding felt like a last minute idea, last minute
attachment, because it felt like they didn't really have an
idea.
Like they just wanted to add a mechanic just to add a
mechanic.
They were like, oh new level.
Let's introduce a new mechanic.
And that's how I felt about the gliding.
But other than that, all the other stuff was fine.
Yeah, it just felt like thrown in just to be like, oh, you
should glide.
Because I always forget the glide.
I always forget to use it because it's like, it felt useless
at points.
Yeah.
Yeah, the telecopter.
But anyway, next week, if everything goes okay, we might
start Armor Core next week.
That was chosen by the member goons.
They chose the schedule.
And they wanted me to start our recording for next week's
stream schedule.
But yeah.
Hey guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posh check.
Get a move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And you said for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
Thank you everybody.
For bearing with me on the PC crashes.
That was very rough.
I always like, you know.
I always am super hard on myself when stuff like that
happens.
Because, you know.
I want you guys to have a great stream experience.
And I know, like, you know, it, like, cuts in and out
randomly and stuff like that.
You know, it might, like, break your focus or, like, get you
on the merge.
So I'm really sorry that that happened.
I'm going to try and look into it.
But thank you guys for bearing with me.
For staying here, despite all the issues that we were going
through.
For toughing it out with us.
I really appreciate you guys.
Thank you guys for the support.
always um and i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys
bye i'm glad everyone had fun i got i'm glad people had fun
we're gonna take pc coon to the hospital now he lost
two-thirds of his blood but i think he'll be okay you might
not have his other leg but it's all right it's all right we
can we can get him a prosthetic or or something it'll be
fine he'll learn how to walk again i believe in him all
right bye guys bye